Has anybody tried to think racism is bad? Does Has Flint ever
heard this one? Hey Nick, did you know that racism bad? Actually,
guys, racism bad. Hold on. There is a 17-year-old girl. A 17-year-old
woman who [laughter]
uh you had a relationship with. Is that >> A 17-year-old
woman.
>> Let's move on to the Candace Owens stuff. Can Owens
responding yesterday to
Megan Kelly Ben Shapiro stuff. Okay.
Okay. I'm excited for today, for the rest of the week because
we have got some very interesting updates for you in the Charlie
Kirk assassination. Uh the assassination that seems to have broken
the brains of Zionists. They are not acting right. Can we all
agree Zionists are not acting right? They are panicking. panicking
so much that they randomly sent Ben Shapiro out into the daylight.
And that [laughter]
Ben Shapiro, you guys ever see the strain? Ben Shapiro is like
the master in the strain. Controls all of his Zogbots. He's got
like the the brain worms and everybody. And he's now he's out.
Listen, he's getting pressured. He's out in the daylight. Okay,
he's out in the daylight. >> That my friends, like I said,
is a move. Okay. Cersei would never send Joffrey. That is a deep
cut, man. Is it really that deep? The stream was a pretty popular
show. I don't think that's a deep cut.
>> I don't think that's that No, I don't think that's that
crazy. Basically just accused him of being Dracula that can control
all the other vampires. Okay. >> Lannister into battle,
right? And they just went ahead and did that. And he
lied to Megan Kelly's face. It is never a good idea to lie. Full
stop. >> Wait, hold on. She She didn't just call him a
Did I hear that correctly?
Yeah, she called him a Lannister.
Bro, I these people don't watch She like has the the the fantasy
references written into her show. She doesn't understand anything.
She never watched these shows.
Like, while that is true, it's like not actually the context
here at all. Okay. Seriously, we never sent Joffrey Lannister
into a battle, right? And they just went ahead and did that.
Dude, that's how Ben Shapiro came up was doing this kind of thing,
talking to people, going on the circuit, arguing with people.
What are you talking about? Ben Shapiro is not Joffrey. >> Uh,
definitely not a good idea to lie to a woman's face and definitely
definitely not a good idea to lie to her face and try to humiliate
her on her own tour. I personally would have strongly advised
against it. Okay, I if somebody said, "Is this a good idea?"
I would said, "Yeah, you know what? Let's maybe not do that."
But it happened. And it's important to stress here that this
was not just a simple mistake that Ben made, right? That's always
a possibility that Ben really thought maybe he's backstage and
see something on Twitter and somebody said Candace just said
that Erica Kirk murdered Charlie and then he gets on stage and
he repeats it. Maybe it's just an accident. Highly unlikely,
but of course you have to run that plausibility. But we can now
confirm that that certainly was not the case. This was not a
simple mistake because in the days following it, he didn't recant.
He did not modify. He did not correct. He has a platform. He
could have just come out and said, "Oh, you know, I I got the
details wrong." Nope. This was a premeditated
and a postmeditated
lie. Okay? intended to morally blackmail Megan into a position
to decide right now on the spot whether you are going to stand
with evil Candace who was accusing Erica Kirk of murdering her
own husband.
And that lie backfired gloriously by the way. Um >> wait
did it >> I think if it had been any other person like
if it was not me >> Wait wait did Megan Kelly Oh I didn't
see the Megan Kelly response. Oh, Candace must be flying high
if Megan Kelly took her side on >> Egging Kelly who was
sitting across from Ben. His strategy would have worked. That
was high pressure, peer pressure.
She happens to be extraordinarily media trained and she didn't
she didn't buck. Okay. She looked uncomfortable, but she did
not bend to his will. She kind of just moved along and said some
stuff about Tucker.
>> See the crazy that Megan Kelly said in defense of Trump.
No.
>> seen the crazy Trump said about her.
>> Asked again like, "Are you sure she said that?" And
he says, "Yes, yes, she said that." And then she found out obviously
that I did not say that. And the following night of her tour
during a Q&A section, somebody named Josh stepped up and
asked her about that moment. And here is what Megan Kelly said.
>> Hi, Megan. >> My name is Joshua. Uh my question
is during a recent stop you had Ben Shapiro as a guest and he
had made some claims about Candace saying that she had said certain
things online and when he made those claims you looked visibly
uncom uncomfortable because you know you hadn't heard that and
couldn't verify that. So my question is uh why did you look so
uncomfortable in that moment and have you researched the claims
that he made since? >> Thank you for that. Yeah. No, he
said that Candace has been claiming Erica Kirk was behind the
murder of Charlie,
which I had not heard, and I was taken aback because that seems
like something I would have heard. It's so crazy. And I have
since learned it is not true.
Candace has not made that claim. And in fact, I've I've now seen
several clips of Candace >> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. Did Megan Kelly investigate this herself or did she
go, "Candace, did you say this?" And Candace was like, "Nah,
I'd never say that."
Which one was it? Cuz I I really hope Megan Kelly she it seems
like she's going to say she saw some clips. Okay, we'll watch
the clips. >> This specifically defending Erica Kirk and
saying she would never make a claim like that about Erica and
that she you know she is open-minded to other people at Turning
Point. That's obvious. She's been making that point. I I had
heard that point. >> But that but she has but she's specifically
been defending Erica Kirk and she's been saying she does not
think >> Yeah. Okay. A lot of people have said though,
I told you she was covering for Candace. Well, here's the thing.
Full of
Do you think Erica Kirk is like deaf?
Do you think Erica Kirk I feel like somehow in my head?
Erica Kirk could easily just she could like end Candace kind
of. She could borderline end Candace or she definitely could
have when Candace started talking.
For some reason, Erica Kirk had no interest in saying anything
about Candace. I don't know why. think that of Erica. And in
fact, if you read her comments, she's under pressure to make
comments about Erica. And so far, what I've seen, she hasn't.
So, thank you for that question.
>> And I'll tell you right now, Megan was not done. >> Uh-oh.
And so, Candace went live and she immediately just thumbmed her
nose at Ben Shapiro.
Nice try, Ben. Nice try, loser. And I will say this, even though
I removed myself from a situation,
it is actually the most disrespectful thing that you can do to
someone that you purport to be friends with or friendly with.
I I can't even imagine that. Like, hey, will you join me on stage?
I really like you and I'm on tour and I'd love to have you on
stage for a discussion. And then this person starts coming after
me and questioning my moral compass. Really process that. That's
just not that's just not cool beyond anything else. So, I was
pretty dumbfounded when Dave Rubin weighed in on the matter and
he called what Ben did effectively trying to humiliate Megan
on her own stage.
He referred to it as almost an act of bravery. Take a listen
to what Dave Rubin says. [music] >> All right. First off,
again, like I know I'm I'm I guess I'm glazing Ben right now,
but he deserves it. It is >> glossing. It's not easy to
go onto someone else's show in general when it's not a live audience
and criticize them, but it's really not easy to do it when you're
in front of thousands of people. I don't know how many people
are at those shows, but it's certainly
Um, you can get you can add it to me. um when thousands of people
uh >> bro I swear to God like if Dave Rubin, Ben Shapiro,
Mark Levvin, if these guys are just like the longest running
SCOP to destroy all of Zionism's credibility, I'm getting close
to believing it. Like they just come out, they never pay attention
like what's going on. They just like say the exact like bot talking
points every single time.
It's crazy.
like like he you said Dave Rubin. I immediately know what Dave
Rubin's opinion is before he's before he shows up on screen.
We all know what his opinion is going to be, right? And it's
like it's so transparent now that we're in this like cultural
moment and like everything's clipped and put on on Twitter. It's
just obvious. We can all see exactly what Dave's going to say.
>> Are there to watch Megan and then you have to criticize
her a little bit. And he did it absolutely respectfully and I
think he did it properly. Listen, I I don't care. Look, I don't
you can tell I don't really want to talk about Tucker. I certainly
don't want to talk about this Nick guy, but sometimes these things
just hit you in the desk. And I agree with Ben. Like, I have
a job to do. And if I don't address the things sometimes that
I don't want to, then I'm probably not very good at my job. And
you should watch another show. Um, I don't really want to talk
about Candace. We were great friends for a long time. She has
been to this house for dinner. She loves Chicken Parm.
>> I can fact check true. I have been to his house for
dinner and I do really love chicken parm. And I had a good one.
Case closed. Onto the next video, guys. Who's got the next video?
That's all we needed to know. >> At his house. I will say
that. I'm not going to front. But the other part that he is saying,
>> you are like, you're an adult. I'm not going to front.
Really? Like, if Candace was somebody who was on Twitter all
day in like all of these circles, was in Discords and
maybe I'd get it. I'm not going to front.
Come on. She doesn't say that. She hangs out with English people.
Her husband is a British royal person. He's like a lord.
She ain't nobody around her says this. That's written in a script
by somebody. The actual black person there, not the adopted one.
>> Yeah. I I don't know what happens when you're a Zionist
where you just on this one topic and this was what it was with
Dave Rubin and why I had to stop being friends with him or friendly
with him is like they just don't know what it actually means
to be a good friend. You do not when you are invited to join
somebody on stage prepare a lie, right? Present them with a lie
and try to peer pressure them in front of their own fans. That's
like there are a million things that could happen before that
ever comes to it. She did not invite him to have a debate. She
invited him to come on her tour and to introduce, you know, to
to have him in front of her audience and to have a conversation
about their values. It's just not the right place, not the right
time. And it really just shows that you're not a good person
cuz you know she probably went backstage, okay, and said hello
to him and was all friendly. If you want to take her to the side
and said, "Hey, I wanted to have a face to face conversation
with you." That's how like regular people would handle something
like that, not try to humiliate you on your own stage. That's
just going to make Megan upset and Megan does eventually do what
I do when I get mad. I double down on the truth, right? That
is what I sentence people to, more truth. And it's fantastic
to just be able to share more truth and you don't have to be
vengeful. You can just share more truth and it's deeply upsetting
to them. And that's what she does. She was literally trending
all weekend.
This
video that she >> That's all Candace does really. She just
shares more truth. Okay. Oh, you you think I'm lying? Well, let
me hit you with a little more truth. was incredibly interesting
because you will recall that after Charlie died, there was basically
just me, Tucker, and >> dude, let me hit you with a little
more truth about the the [clears throat] head of state of France,
who is actually
the father of his wife.
What What is it? Hold on. His wife is his father. His wife is
actually his trans father. Is that eventually where Candace got
to? It's like it's actually insane where the conspiracy around
Emanuel Macron got to and Breijgron
like it got to somewhere totally [__] nuts.
It's uh >> Megan that were trying to say, "Hey, something
like was going on and he was feeling a lot of peer pressure in
the weeks leading up to his death and Zionists were claiming
that's all a lie." And Tucker was like, "No, uh Charlie asked
me explicitly in July to go on stage and to go after Israel trying
to drag us into the Iran war and to I was tell talking to him
about Jeffrey Epstein and I was saying to to Charlie, I won't
do it." And Charlie wanted me to do it, right? And
hold on. Candace is Candace is lying by omission here. She's
like misdirecting, right? The actual thing that I do believe
Charlie wanted
was to not run from those concepts because he felt like there
was a cultural movement behind them and if they ran from those
arguments, those conversations, his organization would look bad.
So he was like, "Oh, I don't want to be accused of running from
these conversations. Please do bring up those topics." It's not
like Charlie was like, "Guys, I'm too scared." So Tucker, I want
you to come on and say that Epste was a MSAD agent. Okay? I'm
too scared to do it, but I need you to come on and do it for
me. That didn't happen. That's not what happened. Come on. >> The
Zionist said that he was lying. I'm going to refresh your memory
here and let you listen to what Tucker claimed that they then
said was a lie.
before that
speech that I gave in July, we had a conversation about this
backstage right before I went on and I was fulminating and getting
all red in the face like I often do to my shame and I was mad
thinking about this and thinking about uh the effort by the neocons
in the United States to draw us in to another forever war with
Iran. It's not a defense of Iran, of course. It's merely an acknowledgement
that we've done this before. Uh this happened in Iraq which uh
you know we we entered into uh at the behest of those same foreign
policy strategists. Um and and it didn't work. And so I was going
on at some length backstage with Charlie and I said uh you know
probably not going to talk about that. I'm not going to torture
you. I know your donors hate this when I say that. Um, and also
Epstein was in the news and it was clear to me that, you know,
Epstein's probably not like a MSAD agent or something, but Epstein
clearly had contact with Israeli intelligence and American intelligence
and French intelligence, but the only one you're not allowed
to talk about is Israeli intelligence. But it's it seemed true
to me and I had done uh some work on that and I knew a bunch
of people pretty close to that story. So So I thought that and
I said that to Charlie and I said, "But I'm not going to say
that because I don't want to make your donors mad. I know. It's
just going to be like an endless
flurry of texts telling you to stop or you're going to lose a
bunch of funding. And he looked at me, I'll never forget it.
And said, "Go all the way. Do it. Go all the way." I said, "Man,
I you know, a lot of things I can talk about. I don't need to
talk about that." And he said, "Do it."
>> So, again, it's exactly what I said where Tucker has
an opinion and Charlie's whole reputation is, "No, I love open
discussion and debate."
Right. That's That's what's actually happening there. It's not
like Candace the way Candace is framing it is like, "Oh, Charlie
like found Tucker and begged him to talk about these things."
It's like, "No, Tucker was like going off and saying, "But I
know I can't talk about it cuz you're donors." And Charlie's
like, "No, no, no. Go ahead. Go off. Go off, gang." >> Yeah.
Like I said, they tried to bury Charlie and a Yamaka and we were
telling you, uh, no, he had a change of heart towards the end.
And I was telling you that Turning Point had captured that.
They were all miked. Okay. So Turning Point captured that and
they could have easily released it to give me a little bit of
backup, but of course that wasn't going to come from them. Well,
just my luck and Tucker's luck that Megan Kelly actually caught
very quickly. Maybe it looks like maybe her assistant's backstage.
I don't know the backstory here, but she was in that discussion
which I had not heard before. And she >> Oh, wait.
There's no way. Wait, there's no way that Megan Kelly backed
up a story about some random person trying to get Charlie Kirk
buried in a yarmaka
>> reveals very quickly you were going to to to hear Charlie
say that Tucker should go for it. >> Oh, the Tucker thing.
Okay, never mind. Never mind. Never mind. >> So, this is
what Megan Kelly released on her show yesterday and you should
go watch the full episode. Take a listen. I found a video of
me, Tucker,
and Charlie
speaking backstage
right before Tucker went out. Tucker and I were talking.
Charlie came over and interrupted for just a second and you can
hear him on this tape, which I've listened to many times. It's
very clear on my phone, less clear here probably as we play it,
but he says to to Tucker, "Go Max." He interrupts the conversation
because he has to say to Tucker something. And what was so important
to him to tell Tucker was, "Go, go, Max." Here it is.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
That's way different than what Tucker said. That totally undermine
Tucker's story where Tucker's like, "Oh, no. I'm not going to
do that because you're donors." And Charlie's like, "Go hard,
bro. Go Max." And Tucker's like, "Yeah, I'm going to the Are
you talking about Tucker's like doesn't give a [__]
about what Charlie just said?"
Watch that again.
>> Tucker was go, Max. Here it is.
>> Literally, literally just gets annoyed that Charlie
even had the gull, the audacity
to interrupt his conversation with Megan Kelly.
He's just like, "Yeah, go." Oh, yeah. I'm going to Yeah, sure.
>> It's quick. It's just happens to be on >> and
it backs up what Tucker said.
>> Well, Charlie, we're going Max now. Okay, because Tucker
told the truth. He had a conversation with Charlie about everything
and Charlie wanted him to go hard. Now Megan's adding to it.
He even interrupted right before he hit the stage and said, "Go
Max. Go Max." Because Tucker I mean because Charlie was done
with these donors. He was done with them. He really was. I I
really don't like it's funny how she has to tell this story with
like
the
thinnest the thinnest justification, the thinnest connection
between these things, right? >> can tell you another story
about which donor was waiting for him once Tucker got off stage
and yelled at Charlie. That was a female uh donor and I will
be outing her later because I don't care about anything right
now. Anyways, point being is we were telling the truth and we
have been facing so much peer pressure, so much nastiness for
just trying to get out the true narrative about where Charlie's
headspace was at before he before he died.
And my favorite part of all of this now is watching them lose.
The people who tried with all of the money in the world to artificially
direct the markets toward them after Charlie died are losing.
[music] Okay. the people who sold t-shirts, who got on stage
and said they were Charlie's favorite pastor, America's pastor.
Um, I'm gonna take over for Charlie. The people who used their
connections, their wealth to get themselves
almost invited to be a part of Charlie Kirk's legacy. People
that didn't even support Charlie Kirk while he was alive. The
people who rushed to lie about me and Charlie's relationship
as close as we were. You guys are losing. I want you to know
that because the market, turns out the market is smarter than
you are. I go back to that Taylor Loren's tweet early on. She's
a hardcore lefty, yet in the immediate aftermath of Charlie's
death. She said, "It's wild that Candace is the only right-wing
ring figure that I've seen posting in a way where she seems genuinely
devastated to have lost Charlie as a friend." >> To be
fair, that was in the couple days right after where you mostly
weren't saying anything and before you uh went live and then
started accusing Turning Point of having him killed. I think
I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure Candace was still just posting
about how upset she was and then she like went started going
live and being like I'm pretty sure Turning But we need to ask
questions about what Turning Point's saying about this
or maybe it was slightly after that. I'm not totally sure. But
>> and why did she tweet that? Well, I have an answer for
that now, Taylor, now that I'm seeing straight because it's becoming
very clear to me that Charlie was a product to everybody else.
He was not a human being. >> Okay, we're going to the Turning
Point lies here. Apparently, Megan Kelly's got a very funny Trump
clip here. We're going to check this out. I'm not sure if we're
going to go from this to more Trump stuff or if we're going to
go on to something. So, there's there's Trump stuff. Let me go
through the docket that we have remaining here. There's Trump
stuff. There's the Fuentes Aiden conversation. There's Lena Khan
talking former head of the FTC, I think. I think
FC
FTC FTC, right? Trade Commission.
Trade Commission. Not not elections.
I'm pretty confident, right? Lena Khan. Okay, I'm just going
to Google it. I was going to ask chat, but I'm just going to
actually Google it cuz I'm
Yeah, FTC. Okay, thank God. I I thought maybe I should bring
that up. She talked to Adam Freeland. We got that. We got some
Warren Smith content. That should be good. Warren Smith basically
trying to do the Ben Shapiro circuit and I think getting kind
of owned by some of his viewers.
All right, [laughter]
>> As for Epstein, I've said this before, but just as a
reminder, I do know somebody very, very close to this case who
is in a position to know virtually everything. Not everything,
but virtually everything. And this person has told me from the
start years and years ago that Jeffrey Epstein in this person's
view was not a this is this person's view who was there for a
lot of this but that he was into the barely legal type like he
liked 15year-old
>> and I I realize this is disgusting. I'm definitely not
trying to make an excuse for this. I'm just giving you facts.
I understand this was on an island, but is 15 legal somewhere
in the States for an adults?
>> Um, that he wasn't into like >> true. I guess
that's barely legal in Germany. [laughter] eight-year-olds, but
he liked the very young teen types that could pass for even younger
than they were, but would look
>> he's kind of Roy Moinesesque in that way. He's a he's
kind of like a Roy Moore kind of guy at heart. Okay. Very roar
Roy Moore coded
>> legal to a passer by. And that is what I believed and
that is what I reliably was told for many years. And it wasn't
until we heard from Pam Bondi that they had tens of thousands
of videos of alleged, forgive me, they used to call it kitty
porn, now they call it child sexual abuse material.
Okay. Does she understand that videos of Jeffrey Epstein a 15-year-old
would be
Is she Is she confused
that both of those statements could be
like uh well I didn't realize that he might be a until they said
they had tens of thousands of hours of child there
like but he just like 15y olds. Yeah, if he was 15y old on a
camera that's called
>> on his computer that for the first time I thought oh
no he was an actual I mean only a gets off on young children
abuse videos. She's never clarified it. Oh, she dude. People
really just just be getting on massive channels like this that
they own, they operate, and they say the most
>> Don't know whether it's true. I have to be honest. I
don't really trust Pam Bondi's word on the Epstein matters anymore.
[laughter] >> Yeah. So, I don't know what's true about
him, but we have yet to see. By the way, I just realized today
that every single time I've ever disconnected these Bluetooth
headphones, it's not the Bluetooth stack in Windows that's up.
It's the audio stack in Windows. So, resetting the headphones
as my primary output device is what actually fixes it. So, I
can actually just flick back and forth between audio devices
and it's like super quick and doesn't interrupt the stream. That's
just not going to happen anymore.
>> I don't know. >> Sorry, let me pull it back. I
interrupt anymore. [laughter] >> Yeah. So, I don't know
what's true about him, but we have yet to see anybody come forward
and say, "I was a like a I was under 10. I was under 14 >> when
I first came within his >> purview." I look, it's you can
say that's a distinction without a >> No, it's not. >> I
think there is a difference. There's There's a difference between
a 15year-old and a 5-year-old. You know, it's just whatever.
That's again C Sam is not just 5-year-olds at all.
Okay, real quick. I don't mind going further into the Trump stuff,
but I don't know. Is there like
the CNN video? I would like to just get the highlights from like
a video if we can cuz I just want to be informed. It's not like
I want to do a whole bunch of like a deep dive on it particularly,
but if there's like a Do you think this would be it? This is
CNN breaking news >> by Jeffrey Epstein that explicitly,
mentioned Donald Trump by name and in context
that we really haven't heard before. Let's get right to Caitlyn
Collins who's got >> Oh, is there is there a Coffeezilla
video? Hold on. Coffeezilla. Coffeezilla is our guy on this one.
But did he do one? New Epstein files just talking about the 20,000.
>> Let's go.
Love me some Coffeezilla.
>> Epstein files that got released. It's a complicated
picture involving a lot of powerful people. But let me just say
right up front, this is an ongoing story. There's a lot that's
going to be released in the coming days. So, just understand,
we're going to do our best to explain what has been happening
because this story has been full of twists and turns. starts
with the Democrats releasing three emails from the Jeffrey Epstein
estate. One says that the dog that hasn't barked is Trump. A
victim spent hours at my house with him. Another says the victim.
Oh, this is all in the Michael Wolf. Wait, why is Michael Wolf
not releasing
Wait, Michael Wolf had this stuff? Didn't Michael Wolf do the
whole documentary? Wasn't he collecting all this evidence? Why
the is Michael Wolf retaining all of this stuff and not doing
anything?
Wait, what?
That doesn't make Well, I think people kind of suspected he was
sitting on stuff. Wasn't it? Wasn't it Bannon? Bannon's also
sitting on some stuff,
Bannon, I think, has a ton of footage with Epste or something
like that. >> Mara Lago Trump says he asked me to resign.
Never a member ever. Jeffrey Epstein. Of course, he knew about
the girls as he asked Galain Maxwell to stop. And then the third
email is from Michael Wolf talking about Jeffrey Epstein's association
with Trump saying, "You can hang him in a way that potentially
generates a positive benefit for you or if it looks like he really
could win, you could save him generating a debt." Basically implying
the idea that Epstein would have some kind of compromising information
on Trump. BUT THAT WAS JUST THE START OF it because then after
that the GOP came out swing and they said >> Roger Stone
said Bannon has like 25 hours of footage or something. Yeah,
Bannon was shooting like a
Bannon was shooting like a documentary or some [__]
Uh relevant to when the woman said earlier she didn't release
Epstein was she didn't said earlier she didn't realize Epstein
was into kids. Oh, or Megan Kelly.
Relevant to the Megan Kelly story. Hold on. What is this? What's
this? What's this? Hold on. >> There is a 17-year-old girl.
>> A 17-year-old woman
uh you had a relationship with. Is that >> A 17-year-old
woman.
>> There's no way it went like that in the actual interview,
but I kind of want Dude, I want to
wait. There's no way that's real. Hold on.
Uh Tucker Carlson, Matt Gates,
dude. It's literally all of the first couple clips are literally
just that.
Wait, what?
>> Wrong one. Wrong one. Hold on. Come on. Show me the
Show me the Tucker Carlson clip. Short videos. No, no, no. Videos.
>> We're just laughing about it. Hold on. >> All
things the Republican strongly denies. It is a horrible allegation
and it is a lie. The New York Times is running a story that I
have traveled with a 17-year-old woman and that is verifiably
false. People can look at my >> Come on. There's got to
be Where's the
is it's all reactions. I don't have anybody with the full video
and see that that is not the case. >> Instead, Gates claims
he and his family are the victim. investigation by the FBI into
Gates's conduct. Carlson said he did not remember the woman or
the >> I I I don't remember the the woman you're speak
>> I do remember I do remember when Matt Gates kind of
like bombs Tucker Carlson though. I do remember this now. Now
that you're now that we're all looking at this again, bro, where
he's like, "What? What are you talking about? You met you met
this woman? Did you think she was 17? We went to dinner with
you and your wife. It's like, haha,
how about you don't how about you don't kamicazi me? I understand
I'm an aircraft carrier and you're a Japanese fighter jet, but
Jesus >> Speaking of or the context at all, honestly, but
I I would like to know who So, they're saying there is a 17-year-old
girl who uh you had a relationship with. Is that true? And who
are they who is this girl? What are they talking about? The New
York Times. >> The person doesn't exist. I have not had
a rel >> Oh, okay. It's a little different. 15year-old
girl who uh you had a >> Nope. Nope. Nopeers. Nopers.
Got it.
Yeah, we watched that already. We're This is literally in reference
to that wombo combinator. Just laughing about
Uh well, I didn't realize I thought Jeffrey Epste just like 15year-olds.
I didn't realize he had CSAM on his
Mhm. Democrats whine about releasing the files, but they only
cherrypick when they have them to generate clickbait. You deserve
the full truth. And then they released over >> Yeah, Koko,
I didn't want to say it, but I thought the clip in that exact
order, the like Instagram reel, I thought that was what it was,
but it's not. >> 20,000 files. Some of it had to do with
Trump, some of it didn't. Importantly, two of the emails that
were in there were some of the ones that the Democrats released,
except they were unredacted in the GOP copy. And these lack of
redactions are obviously very intentional. So we see first, I
want you to realize the dog that hasn't bked is Trump. And then
it says, Virginia spent hours at my house with him. Now that
name is really important. >> Virginia Guffy. What? Trump
spent hours with Virginia Guthrie.
Bruhant because it's Virginia.
She was the prince and
wait there's no way that's how you say that name.
You Virginia Juy
I've only ever heard it said Guffrey
and this guy just said Jay
true accuser but importantly she did not accuse Trump rather
saying that he couldn't have been friendlier. This obviously
is one of the main reasons the GOP appears to have released this
because in part they're implying that hey if you release this
redacted people are going to speculate who this victim was thinking
that there was something that happened but actually the person
that's in there didn't accuse Trump of something illegal and
so this is sort of the implication here with the Democrats saying
well you're you're unredacting a victim's oh it is Jay godamn
name. So that's been the battle there. Specifically, the second
email, by the way, just further confirms it. It says blank worked
at Mara Lago. She was one of the ones that accused Prince Andrew.
In the Democrat copy, all of that was redacted because, of course,
it gives away the fact that we are talking about once again Virginia
Duayra. Also, in these emails released by the Republicans, it
says, "Blank worked at Mara Lago. Trump knew of it, came to my
house many times. He never got a massage." That's straight from
Jeffrey Epstein clearing him of a massage, which obviously is
the one person you most don't want to get a massage from. So,
honestly, that is good for him, which is obviously why they released
it. Begging the question why they didn't release it sooner. Maybe
it's because they didn't want people to know that Trump knew
about the girls. Now, one thing I want to talk about is the fact
that Epstein is saying, "Hey, look, Trump publicly said that
it was me that he asked to stop, but actually it was Gain that
he asked to stop." And my question here is if it is Maxwell that
was the one who poached Virginia Du Fray from Mara Lago and then
trafficked her then >> wait wait Trump was like hey could
you stop like taking my employees to turn into slaves?
Um can you can you stop doing that? I really don't like that.
Can you can you stop? >> Why is she getting so much special
treatment? I mean that is the part where the Republicans don't
look good at all. I mean, what what is going on with Galileain
Maxwell, a convicted defender, trying to get a pardon, getting
Todd Blanch to give her a softball interview, and then she immediately
gets preferential treatment. Look, we've been over the fact that
she's at basically a special prison in Brian, Texas, where normally
someone of her status, >> I'm still listening. I got to
be right back in 2 seconds here. >> Wouldn't be allowed
to go to because it's too nice. It's too low security. But in
addition to that, new reports are saying that top officials at
Camp Bryan are sick of being Maxwell's [__] Federal
law enforcement staff working at the camp have been waiting on
Maxwell hand and foot, including, by the way, reportedly she's
been given a puppy as part of the preferential treatment she's
been receiving. Overwhelmingly, Maxwell has been getting a super
nice ride in all of this. This, of course, makes us all wonder
once again, what do they have on Trump? I mean, what? Like, why
treat her like this if she doesn't have something compromising
in all of that? It just kind of begs some questions you probably
don't want to ask. Also very suspicious is the fact that immediately
after this report came out, Trump personally called Rep. rep.
Lauren Boowbert, urging her to withdraw support for releasing
the Epstein files. Bondi, Blanch, and Patel, we're going to meet
today about the Epstein files. This, of course, is furthering
the idea. The White House has no interest in this story. I think
Trump tweeted multiple times today about the Epstein hoax again.
We've heard that a million times. And the question,
Dude, I
Why? Yeah, I like Listen,
I understand treating people humanely. I understand some of the
arguments around, you know, not demonizing.
If somebody's a convicted defender, you're going to give them
a puppy.
idea guys about the the sound stack versus the Bluetooth stack.
I lied about that. It's actually still breaking. So, good luck.
Have to reconnect this.
Reconnecting these headphones. My voice should go out one more
time. Hello.
We're back. Cool. All right.
Question is, why are you acting so suspicious if you have nothing
to hide? Right. If you didn't get the massage, which Epstein
says, why why what are you hiding? Why why are you so worried
about all this stuff coming out? By the way, press secretary
Caroline Levit was actually asked about the White House pressuring
people to get them not to sign for the release of the Epstein
files, and her response was pretty insane. >> Why are White
House officials then meeting with Representative Boowbert in
an effort to try and get her to to not sign this petition uh
calling for the release of the files? Doesn't it show transparency
that members of the Trump administration are willing to brief
members of Congress whenever they please? Doesn't that show our
level of
Hey, we're like doing the corruption out in the open. Doesn't
that show the level of transparency?
Um, you know, I didn't I didn't actually think about it that
way. I never thought about it like that. Doesn't that show the
level of transparency [clears throat] when we are willing to
sit down with members of Congress and address their concerns?
>> It shows transparency to try to go and block files being
released on the world's most prolific.
But the fact we know about it, that's the transparent part. It's
just insane. I mean, that's the kind of spin we've expected with
this story all along. That's been part of what's been so frustrating
about all of this. Uh, so look, I want to get back to this story
because there's so many people involved here. Uh, we're just
going to go through one by one. I mean, look, it's a lot more
than just Trump. Like, one person that got kind of a weird stray
in all of this was the fact that Epstein talked about Hillary
doing naughties with Vince. Uh, Vince being Vince F.
Dude, could you imagine if it comes out like could you imagine
if this is just a year of like every skitso conspiracy theorist
having like all of their ideas come true. You get like proof
that Hillary Clinton and or the Clintons in general Vince Foster.
You get like a whole bunch of things just revealed. It's all
true. Foster a White House counsel. There was a rumor about Clinton
and Vince having some kind of affair and then later Vince was
found dead of and this is where we
Okay.
Should
we I maybe this is one of those things that I should nail down
forever right at this exact moment.
Was Vince Foster really found like tied up with bullets in the
back of his head and they ruled. That's what you always hear
that Vince Foster had two bullets through the back of his skull.
It was ruled as and his hands were like tied behind his back
or some [__]
Is that Is that actually true? I always hear that and I'm like
there's no way that's true. That can't possibly be
right? But what is true?
Why do people believe Vince Foster
himself or oh, sorry, didn't kill himself. Didn't kill himself.
Pull perplexity over. Why do people believe this?
Thinking, thinking, thinking, thinking.
Okay, sometimes it freezes there.
Many people believe Vince Foster didn't kill himself due to persistent
conspiracy theories and doubts about the circumstances of his
death, despite multiple official investigations, concluding it
was caused by depression. I have separate investigations.
No signs of foul play, such as missing fingerprints or evidence
the body had been moved.
Yeah. I figured this is one of those things that's actually just
a conspiracy theory. Probably.
>> I think so.
Anyway,
see Jeffrey Epstein and Michael Wolf's kind of symbiotic relationship.
Michael Wolf is a journalist who has been prolific in all of
this. Well, I struggle to call him a journalist actually because
that's what we'll find. He was more like a PR guy for Epstein,
but he was actually asking Epstein and using Epstein for a lot
of access to information because Michael Wolf actually told Jeffrey
Epste, "Hey, basically I'm interviewing him this afternoon. Anything
you think I should ask?" And he's talking about Trump.
Epstein replies, do you want to be provocative?
Mike Wolf says, "Job is to get the hard ones in without being
ejected from the room. What's the one that pierces through?"
Jeffrey Epstein basically says, "Hey, you can do this softball."
That's a Hillary problem. He would smile and then you can ask
about his relationship with the electricians union and Mara Lago
and out you go. Obviously hinting to the idea that he's going
to get kicked out if he asks about more sensitive subjects. Michael
Wolf asks about, "Hey, what's up with Foster?" And then he describes
what that's all about. And this brings us to Michael Wolf, who
I want to spend a little bit of time here on. Although some of
you may not know as much about >> this Michael Wolf guy
is very suspicious right now to me >> about him. You may
be less interested in him. I think he's one of sort of the worst
looking people in all of this. Actually, [laughter] >> just
on a
on a physiotomy level, okay, on a phenotypic level, this guy
is a disaster. after reading these emails, he may be the most
disgusting person that comes out of that. And that's saying a
lot given what's in here, but I want to just show you this because
actually the Democrats initially released was this idea was that
Michael Wolf and Epstein were basically planning how to respond
to Epstein being brought up in the context of Trump. Michael
Wolf says, "I hear CNN is planning to ask Trump about his relationship
with you either on air or in Scrum afterwards." Epstein says,
"If we were able to craft an answer for him, what do you think
it should be?" That being interesting because it's like, "Wait,
were they in touch with Trump at this time?" Because Trump denied
being in contact with Epstein basically since early 2000s. But
anyway, if he says he hasn't been on the plane or to the house,
and that gives you valuable PR or political currency, you can
hang him in a way.
>> The big piece I thought I saw here was didn't Trump
accept like a hund sorry, a $30 million loan from Epstein some
somewhat recently, like around this time. that generates a positive
benefit for you. Or if it really looks like he could win, you
could save him generating a debt. Of course, it is possible that
when asked, he'll say Jeffreey's a good guy that's gotten a raw
deal and victim of political correctness, which is to be outlawed
in the Trump regime. Now, if it doesn't sound like PR, it might
be something like blackmail to you. It's like kind of a little
bit of both. Michael Wolf is basically conspiring to generate
a debt for Jeffrey Epstein from Trump who is about to become
the most powerful person on the planet. So that's really bizarre
because Michael Wolf has positioned himself as sort of this truth
teller about Jeffrey Epstein and oh and he's got all these tapes
that he's going to release showing how close Trump and Epstein
were. But it's like behind the scenes he was actually kind of
running PR for Epstein like which is sort of the worst thing
you could have ever done. Uh this is in 2016. Michael Wolf is
talking to Epstein about a Patterson book which later becomes
the James Patterson Filthy Rich book. He says basically that
would present some time issues if it was released too early.
You would not be able to do a competing book or documentary before
then. That's not to say it shouldn't be pursued. in a sense better
to know what Patterson's position is and a year from now be able
to counter it in 2016. He's playing like PR I'm gonna fix your
reputation Jeffrey Epstein. He then says that being said if you
need an immediate counter to the book I believe Trump offers
an ideal opportunity. It's a chance to make the story about something
other than you while at the same time letting you frame your
own story. also becoming an anti-Trump voice gives you a certain
political cover which you decidedly don't have now. And so again,
we get the idea of >> I speed up >> kind of scheming
to get Epstein. >> I'm seeing something. Listen, my ADHD
is kicking in a little bit. I see
Kyle Kolinsky has decided to
fire a shot across the bow at Asminold.
Make it stop. Asminold shatters the meter.
Um, the Kyle Golinsky show. Might have to cue that up. Okay.
Very excited. >> Which is so bad because now Michael Wolf
is like, "Oh, we're the guy exposing Trump's connections to Epstein."
It's like, "Buddy, what are your connections to Epstein?" Then
we have later them discussing a lawsuit against Epstein and Donald
Trump. With a woman claiming that she was Michael Wolf responds,
well, I guess if there's anyone who can wave this away, it's
Donald. Let me know if there's anything I can do. again, why
are you trying to do something for a man accused of these things?
It really seems like Michael Wolf was kind of running cover here.
Now, I also want to talk about the Prince Andrew Trump scandal
that appears to have been brewing here, or at least is implied
in the emails. You may see some people say that Epstein met Trump
and Prince Andrew back in 2019, which of course would be well
after Trump said they had no contact, which would be bad news
for Trump. In fact, there's a few things in here which suggest
that Epstein had contact with Trump. Of course, we don't know
for sure. I'll just present you the evidence we do have. So,
this is back in 2019, June 3rd. They're talking about London,
about London real estate, about how financials are going to leave.
Then, Epstein says, "Once they are gone, the monarchy is dependable,
saying Prince Andrew and Trump today. Too funny." And this is
actually the same day that Trump and Andrew are spotted in London,
of course, meeting together. Jeffree, >> oh man,
>> crazy Eskimo brother photo right there. Epstein says,
"Recall Prince Andrew's accuser came out of Mara Lago, Virginia
Du Fray." Then we have a Cinder that's blacked out, but I think
there's strong evidence that it's Steve Bannon, by the way, just
to give you some context. They say, "Can't believe nobody is
making you the connective tissue." So, the connective tissue
between these two being Epstein. And then Epstein replies, "FB
only." Now later, Jeffrey Epstein says, "Report from London.
Donald now thinks he's king. Ivanka a princess. He doesn't need
advisers." Bannon says, "Yep, London trip not good. He had a
gleam in his eye." Of course, this hinting at the idea that Epstein
was there if he got a report from London. He's talking about
Prince Andrew and Trump or that's how people are coming to that
conclusion at least. And then we have the thread that makes us
know this is Steve Bannon, which is he gives a link where it
says Steve Bannon believes Trump obstructed justice. Michael
Wolf says he says he crushed him. He should give it up. The book
is going to be a stiff. I don't know if he senses that. Epste
replies, "Unfortunately, I do know his comments have encouraged
some to look to you for answers." This all being about an article
about Steve Bannon, obviously. And then Steve Bannon says, "Burke
says, I have zero to worry about." Now, if you don't know who
Burke is, he's a lawyer who previously defended Steve Bannon.
Epste then replies, "Good, but unnecessary. Should I call Mike
Michael Wolf?" Bannon says, "What are you going to say to him?
He's a wild animal caught in a trap." Epste says, "Catch his
breath." Bannon says, "Tell him to lay off me. It's both not
working and not helping." Okay, done. Again, this is all in the
context of Michael Wolf talking about Steve Bannon. And then
he says, "Hey, tell him to back off." This is furthering the
idea that Epstein, Bannon, Michael Wolf, they all had a close
relationship, which is mostly public knowledge, but we see exactly
how close. Now, in addition to this, I also wanted to note this
very strange interaction between these two where Epstein sends
a news article about George Nater being basically caught up in
some child charges. And then Bannon says, "Not cool." Epstein
mandatory minimum 15. Bannon says NBZ must have coughed him up.
How did he get extradited? He could have stayed in UAE forever.
Epstein says he was not extradited. He was duped.
Is that intentionally NBZ or because I would assume NBS
>> But was that is that a mistype NBZ?
>> Bannon, WTF, Epstein, there is his bail hearing today
currently in Brooklyn. Doesn't look good. Pre-trial detention.
Now, I personally thought it strange that they were so concerned
about the fate of someone caught up in such horrible charges.
Uh, we'll also talk about the Thanksgiving message. This one
got a lot of attention, which is that Epstein was going to Thanksgiving
and he was asked, "Where are you having Thanksgiving?" He says,
"Eva, this lady, >> I know NBS wouldn't have anything to
do with the UAE,
>> but NBZ is UAE." Okay. Okay. I just assumed Middle East
powerful person who could give him up. NBS
>> NBC. Dude, what's going on with his music, man? Where
did this go to? The
What the heck? No, not that. Back to
Thank you.
Oh, yeah. Muhammad bin Zed al- Na Nayan,
third president of the United Arab Emirates. Okay, let's go.
Dude, how did they how did Coach Red
get into this gig? Assumed office May 14th, 2022. Wait, when
did Coach Red Pill die?
When did this guy die?
Oh, 2024. Okay. I feel like I see it. Am I? I can't be the only
one who sees it,
I cannot be the only one who sees that
himself off became president of the United Arab Emirates. Really
moving up. One of the things that's been not yet, Kyle. Not yet.
Holy faith. Kate replies, "He's such a snooze. Who else is down
there?" He replies, "David Fizzle, Hansen, Trump." And once again,
Trump claims that he was not in contact with Jeffrey Epstein
after the early 2000s. He said, "Hey, I cut him off. I realized
he was a bad guy." And if Epstein's having Thanksgiving with
him, that's obviously a problem. Now, I don't have any public
confirmation for that outside of these emails, which are basically
talking about it, implying it. Once again, the same is true of
Prince Andrew. Do you actually think these emails are about him
actually seeing them, or is he just reporting on it? It's It's
kind of hard to know, but I just want you to know what's out
there. You also should know about the foreign governments that
Epstein was working with. In one email, you have Jeffrey Epstein
talking about advising a Russian ambassador. He says Churkin
was great. He understood Trump after conversations. It's not
complex. And Churkin was a Russian ambassador at the time until
he died. And then you also have Israel. There are a bunch of
public reports about Israel being implicated with Epstein, how
spies stayed with him at the time, and some of them even met
at
>> Okay, this this is honestly borderline unfair with the
title I just saw. Seems like a top MSAD spy was Ahood Barack's
like aid, like top aid. Makes sense that somebody high up in
your government might be the aid for a former prime minister.
It could just be a cover, but like it's also
truly spy stayed with uh for weeks at a time with Jeffrey Epstein
uh on wire transfer to Ahood Brock's top aid, Yonyi Corin, who
regularly stayed at his apartment.
It's like, yeah, well, it's not really shocking. All these guys
do time in the military. They all do, lots of them do time in
intelligence.
ated with Epstein, how spies stayed with him at the time, and
some of them even met at Epstein's house. And then you also have
some emails between Epstein and a UAE royal, a sultan. So Epstein
was he was rubbing shoulders with the top the top cream of the
crop of our society. I mean, I don't think that should come as
a shock. Uh we should also probably talk about Larry Summers.
He was in an article, Mogul Donor Gives Harvard More Than Money.
And then he is in emails with Larry Summers where Epstein tells
him, "When we meet, I will endeavor to mesmerize you with stories
of DC." So wild. And then Larry Summers said, "I am trying to
figure out why American elite think if you murder your baby by
beating an abandonment, it must be irrelevant to your mission
at Harvard, but hit on a few women 10 years ago and can't work
at a network or think tank. Do not repeat this insight." Oops.
Now everybody has it. So there you go. I mean, that's a highlevel
snapshot. Do not say this anywhere of what we saw in this release.
Lots of people being implicated in one way or another. It's quite
varied. I mean, you know, some people you find out they've been
>> I didn't know he had those kinds of connections. We
talked about it on stream a couple times. Kuroko to Msad and
and to Israel. Yeah. Like he was he was really close friends
with Ahoud Barack, former prime minister of Israel.
I say that's known. I We've covered a couple different things
on it, but maybe it's just not that well known. Okay, I've got
a couple things here. I want to cover this guy. this Star Gun
of AOD video. Haven't watched this yet. Porter Beller sent it
to me. He said he didn't watch it either, but it's apparently
>> Sargon Gun of AOD's short treatise on why Nick Fuentes
is popular. The old conservatives must change. I
would watch this. I know some people I know a lot of people don't
like Sargon.
It's hard to say that he hasn't been effective in some ways,
right? As a media person, he has been effective. as a politician,
he's kind of been an ab like an abject failure, but as a as a
political voice in media, I think he's been quite successful.
I think it's hard to argue he's been unsuccessful.
So, I kind of want to see what he'll have to say here just cuz
he's in that same sphere or he's he's treated in he's treated
like a
a little bit close to a Fentes.
Little bit close. Okay. First though,
Asmin Gold shatters the meter. I think this is going to be Asmin
Gold's rant. We didn't get a chance to cover this cuz I was off,
but this will be Asmin Gold's whole rant about how like Republicans
really get treated badly and Democrats get passes on everything.
I knew that would give a lot of people an aneurysm. Is that Asmin
Gold like trying to do psychic damage to every Midas tube like
slot tuber that exists?
You just wanted to say something that would destroy all of these
people's mental one statement. He just snaps and 50% of the mental
stability of the entire Midas touch the entire Midas touch network
just like takes a hit, just disappears, turns into dust. This
is the power of Asmin Gold. Driving me crazy more and more lately
is uh when you have people who have large audiences who don't
know what the [__] they're talking about, but they're
just desperate to start giving their political takes and opinions
because um look, you do a massive disservice.
>> Hey, Asmin Gold's been doing this for a long time. He
didn't just start Kyle. Uh fact check. Asmin Gold has been giving
his [__] opinion for like a decade on politics.
Um, this didn't just happen, Kyle. Asold's been in the sphere
for a long time. Longer than you, actually. He was in a debate.
Didn't you see him moderate that debate between Fentes and Hassan
and Sargon? Oh, that's another that's another way Sargon's tied
to Fuentes,
One second. We're just doing some [__] here. that's
uh nervous. You have this giant audience of people who follow
you and if you're out there spreading false notions of politics.
Um that's unacceptable. That's unacceptable. The best example
of this is [__] Joe Rogan who doesn't know his ass
from his elbow. But uh he's out there. He was at the inauguration.
He gave Trump a softball interview. Gave JD Vance a softball
Hot stone. Asminold is significantly more terrifying than Joe
Rogan. Okay. The thing nobody ever wants to point out about Asmin
Gold or sorry, nobody ever wants to point out about Asmin Gold.
Him and Fuentes, both of them, okay?
They don't grow from collaborations,
right? Like they essentially don't do collaborations. That what's
that's what makes them way different. Joe Rogan grows from collabs.
Every big like Rogan sphere influencer, they all maximize
Asminold is a religion onto himself. Nick Fuentes is a religion
onto himself, right? It's it's purely centered around these people.
They're way different animals than somebody like Joe Rogan. Possibly
less harmful. I'm not saying it's about harm, but like they're
they're way different animals. Looking at them the same way is
pretty crazy. Massages every billionaire in the country on his
show regularly, but then he'll go on a show and so who me, bro?
I'm just like a centrist. I'm like I'm not right. I'm not left.
I'm sort of above the fray and stuff. Like it's whatever. He
tries to do this enlightened centrist bit. Meanwhile, he's like,
you know, on the Trump train quite literally. So, >> um,
he's a great example of it. But another one is Asmin Gold. Asmin
Gold. He's been getting more and more political. Um, and I just
I mean, I hear this, I just want to shove my nuts in >> Joe
Rogan is a lip tart. He's pro >> Uh, yes. Joe Rogan's like
a third positionist. He just doesn't know it. >> Waffle
iron when I hear this cuz like what do you Did he just say he
wants to stick his in a waffle iron? >> Just I mean, I
hear this. I just want to shove my nuts in a waffle iron when
I hear this. >> His balls. His balls. I got it. because
like what are you saying? What are you saying? You you know you
don't know what you're talking about. You know you don't know
what you're talking about. But he does it anyway. So here he
is giving his theory about how you know the Democrats they've
been so radicalized that the Republicans are the poor put upon
Republicans. They're just like reacting to what the insane Democrats
are doing. I'M NOT KIDDING. I'M NOT KID. That's his actual argument.
Let's watch. This is a uniquely I think it is a unique Democrat
problem. Now when a Republican does something bad, here's the
big difference, right? It's not that Republicans don't do anything
bad, but when a Republican does something bad, everybody generally
says, "Oh, okay. That's [laughter] really bad." But the
>> dude, the amount I watch this guy sweep for Tom Hman
is so nuts,
it's crazy.
And then I have to hear him go, "Listen, most people when Republicans
do something bad, they just say it's bad."
Kyle Kyle is uh having a hard time, too. is that Democrats look
to try to, you know, like, oh, it's not that big of a deal. It
doesn't matter that much. Who >> Now, do you understand
why I said this made me want to shove my nuts in a waffle iron?
Homie literally said >> I do. I actually Kyle I laughed
at Kyle when he said it a little bit and then I was like, you
know what? Once again,
Kyle Kolinsky W. Okay. This guy can't stop He can't stop winning.
He's just correct.
When a Republican does something bad, other Republicans can be
like, "Yeah, that's bad.
That might actually be the least true thing I've ever heard in
my life. That is somehow the most false thing I've ever heard
in my entire life.
Asmin Gold, bro.
Let me just tell let's let's just go with Elon. Why has a ball
video on the side? What your ball size says about
ASAP science seven days ago. No idea. What did Elon do when he
was running Doge? You guys all know this. How many times have
I given you the list? He cut pediatric cancer research.
Not a single Republican came out. Not a single Republican came
out and criticized him for cutting child cancer research. By
the way, there was one of those things was literally a cure that
worked. I'm not kidding. It was a gene editing thing that they
used to stop leukemia. They tried it on somebody, it worked.
He cut the funding. He cut the National Weather Service, which
literally led to deaths. It led to deaths. There was a a late
warning that went out because he cut the National Weather Service.
And uh you have these kids at a Christian Sleepaway Camp who
died. He cut meals on wheels. He cut the Consumer Financial Protection
Bureau, which is the anti-scam police. No Republicans criticized
any of these things. None of them. He fired 83,000 veterans.
Nobody criticized it. He fired 250,000 government workers overall.
Nobody criticized it. When he cut us a cutting off malaria medication
from going to people who need it, HIV medication, people have
been dying in droves. They didn't [__] criticize
it. Are you out of your minds? And that's just and that's just
Elon. I Oh, how long do we got? We got I think we're three subs
away from another hour on the stream, guys. Three subs or
or $16. One of the two. Three subs, 16 bucks. Either one gets
us another hour on the stream. So if you guys you want more time,
go ahead, dig deep into your hearts, into your wallets,
throw a Fiverr at the stream. All right. Thank you guys for being
here. Even mentioned Trump. Trump has been bombing random dingy
fishing boats with innocent people in them.
>> Bruce Willis, thank you for the gifted sub. Let's go.
>> And nobody on the right has been criticizing it at all.
They've all been lying and pretending these are narotists and
Trump has killed the right people and stuff. This is insane.
This is insane.
Even if they were
uh you know trafficking narcotics, the penalty is not instant
death. Are you Are you ridiculous? Oh my god. We're only 24 seconds
into a two-minute clip. I don't know if I could
I [laughter] don't know if I might like have an aneurysm on air.
Ever think about how like Republicans get away with with nothing
and Democrats get away with everything like oh it's not that
big of a deal. It doesn't matter that much. Who cares? And I
think that that is >> Yo, Marma dude, thank you for the
500 kicks. That's a Fiverr. Let's go.
Hold on. I missed the message. What was the message? I missed
the message, guys. Republicans are bad. What do you want me to
say? WD
YW
MTS? What do you want me to say? Radicalized a lot of people.
And I'll view that and and we can contrast this now with do you
remember whenever they had all those text message leaks and it
was all those young Republican people talking about how much
they liked and nobody really cared about that anymore. And the
reason why it's because leftwing people have established a basically
a standard and now right-wing people are living up to it. He
flipped the truth exactly on its head.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
>> Hold on. Hooligans, thank you for the gifted sub. Well,
that I think that is another hour right there. I think by your
powers combined, we've added another another hour to the stream.
Two subs, 500 kicks. Let's go.
This is insane. It's been the exact opposite. My entire adult
life, it's been the opposite. There was literally a slogan that
the Democrats had about how much we're
Michelle Obama came out and said, "When they go low, we go high."
That dominated a generation of Democratic thought. When they
go low, we go high.
And then what happened? The Republicans decided to shatter the
filibuster record under Obama. Obama literally
Turns out the Democrats shins were not ready for the Republicans
going low. Okay, maybe they should have done some low kicks.
They should have practiced a little bit like somebody does Muay
Thai, right? You know how you get those bone spurs that make
your your tibia really hard so you can kick people. Democrats
needed some of that. The Republicans got really good at going
low. All right. And they just started breaking ankles out here.
Came out and said, "I I'm going to propose your ideas, Republicans.
I'm going to do the things you say you love. I'm going to do
a healthcare plan that came from the Heritage Foundation, a right-wing
think tank. And Mitt Romney, the Republican, did it in Massachusetts
as the governor. I'm going to do your plan. And Republicans had
previously all supported this plan as soon as Obama proposed
it. We're against it. WE'RE AGAINST IT. HOW DARE YOU? It's communist
for us to do the healthcare plan that we came up with.
This is who we're dealing with. They broke the filibuster record.
They
uh instantly rejected their own ideas. Obama would do things
like cut small business taxes and they would attack him for it.
Even though again that's their ideas.
>> You want to talk about radicalized?
100% is the exact opposite. Democrats and liberals and leftists
have been radicalized by Republicans being so insane. Trump tried
Okay, I'm I'm enjoying this rant. Well, let me confirm with Cyber
really quickly.
>> Wait, what? To coup the government. >> Crazy going
on. Trump lost an election to Joe Biden and then he did fake
elector slates, which was illegal by the way, but he got got
away with it. Then they had January 6, the violence at January
6th. Even after the violence, Trump was still making phone calls
saying, "Don't certify Joe Biden." He was asking politicians
not to certify Joe Biden.
That's insane. That is insane.
And so they do the extreme [__] They do the crazy,
but somehow we're the problem.
We're the ones who never criticize our own. Are you kidding me?
How quickly do Democrats throw throw each other under the bus?
Yeah. I hate to break away from Kyle here, but we have uh some
breaking
Some breaking news. Lauren de Laguna
has not posted her full video yet, but she did post a video.
This is the video such as it is. >> Got a new bunch of
new follows due to the Dusty drama. So, I'm just going to briefly
state what happened. Um, I was at my job and Destiny and Lauren
Southern showed up where I was working tonight and just like
were patrolling the area that I worked. They I moved from Florida
to Texas to get away from Destiny when I was a public defender
in
>> So yes, apparently
from from
this guy can't stop.
So yeah, apparently he's hanging out with Lauren
>> Florida. He sent attorneys to my place of work to send
me a subpoena. He had my ability to do it at home. He had multiple
different ways to do it, but he decided to disrupt me at work.
>> Oh, wait, hold on. Destiny said he was just out there.
Is she's not saying that he delivered the subpoena himself, is
is she?
That's all that's not what he did. That would be a crazy thing
to do to take Lauren Southern to drop a subpoena off. I >> the
public defender in Florida, he sent attorneys to my place of
work to send me a subpoena. He had my ability to do it at home.
He had multiple different >> I see no attorneys >> ways
to do it, but he decided to
>> disrupt me at work. And now he's doing that again. He's
telling me that he's going to like ruin my career and that my
life is over and that I'm and like I haven't done anything to
this man. I'm not Pixie. He's a turkey. He lied about that. He's
filed bar complaints. He's tried to get me stripped of my license.
I haven't done anything to this man other than I dated him and
then broke up with him and now he's
so apparently apparently
she hang out with or he's hanging out with Lauren Southern again
>> place of work to send me
to Texas to get away from Destiny. When I was a public defender
in Florida, he >> Okay, so she's not talking about now.
when she was a public defender in Laura in Florida in I read
Lauren Laura
in Florida she got apparently served at her her place of work
looking she's not yeah I don't know who believes she's Pixie's
attorney it's kind of silly I have I also have no idea what might
have happened here like
oh how do I put this
I played the fifth on like
on whether or not I feel like Lauren
could have done something questionable. Okay. But I just need
to see evidence of it. Like I I I don't necessarily think Lauren
has the best reputation, but Destiny has a worse reputation and
that he lies openly about a ton of people, right? He just like
makes up about so many people. So, while I don't necessarily
have a lot of trust in Lauren's reputation, I would need to see
some evidence that she's he's done sorry that she's done any
of the he says because I swear to God he's building a whole case
there with with things like the dot dot dot conspiracy.
>> I don't know. I don't know, man. I don't know about
that. What was that? Was Macho with a gifted sub. Thank you very
much, Machico.
>> Okay. Okay. That was the Lauren thing.
So, Destiny back with Lauren Southern, hanging out, chilling,
having a great
Like, what are the odds they just randomly meet each other outside
of her place of work?
I don't know. I don't know, man. I have no idea.
That's not my purview. That's not my my job to know.
I do think it'd be very funny if you could somehow show that
he was trying to find her in that area like by her job. But
that's one of those things where it's like that that would be
interesting. That would make him look really crazy.
But also,
it's entirely possible he did it randomly, I guess. I don't know.
We'll just have to see.
We'll just have to see, man.
She looked a little casual for work.
Uh, well, she might have been leaving work. Also, you don't know
that she works like she works as a lawyer in Texas.
She was a part of the bar in Florida. She moved to Texas. I don't
know if she's a lawyer again in Texas.
So, anyway, we'll go back to Kyle. Remember Al Franken? Al Franken
was a senator. There was a picture that he took where he was
like fake grabbing somebody's while they were sleeping. That
picture came out. He used to be a comedian, by the way. He didn't
actually touch the woman, but he was like fake grabbing the and
like laughing at it and joking about it. He had to resign cuz
other Democrats threw him immediately under the bus. Are you
out of your
They threw him under the bus. It's like a decorum thing.
I I swear to God that's like a good principle to have. Like,
oh, we don't want people here who don't respect the office. It's
just the Republicans don't care.
It's like I don't think it's a bad bar to have. It's just like,
oh, the other side doesn't care and the other side has a whole
bunch of people who just don't give a what do we do? I I keep
saying minds. Are you out of your mind? I mean, it's just it's
this is ridiculous. This is absolutely ridiculous. Nothing could
be further from the truth. It was Donald Trump who came along
and he sort of he sort of defined this idea of be a bull in a
china shop, never apologize, always always plow through and then
eventually people just move on and you're good. So he started
that. We're just getting to the time now. >> Wait, are
you Do you know where Wait, do you know where Madison Cawthorne
is?
What do you mean? Where's Madison
now where Democrats are finally catching up to that? Is Madison
Cawthorne the guy who is the guy who like in one of the chambers
of in Congress or like one of the the primary rooms where they
hold the That's not Madison Cawthorne, right? Madison Cawthorne's
the wheelchair guy who did a bunch of gay.
Okay. Okay. It was just staffers who did that, right? Do you
guys remember that?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It was just staffers. Okay. Right. That's just
starting to happen now. And thank god it is. Cuz here's the deal.
We can only have civility into quorum if both sides agree to
civility and decorum. It's that simple. As soon as the Republicans
go you then we have to say you back. It's like with the gerrymandering
fight. By the way, Asmin, who's the one that gerrymandered first?
It was Texas and the Republicans that said, "We're just going
to gerrymander and steal a bunch of Democratic seats and turn
them Republican." Greg Abbott did that because Trump told him
to do that. And then it had that had to happen before you had
Nuome step up and say, "All right, if you're going to do that,
then we're going to counter Jerry Mander in California." Newsome
didn't start that. The Democrats didn't start that. Republicans
started that. We responded in kind. Democrats and liberals and
leftists responded in kind. So he has it exactly wrong. He has
it exactly
These are unhinged and out of control and radical. And because
of that, it's this is like, by the way, it's really funny that
Asminold has this sobering effect. This is probably the most
coherent and on point I've ever heard Kyle Kolinsky. Kyle Klinsky
always got to throw some random conspiracy [__] in.
He's always got to be like a little too over the line, but it's
just like fact fact fact.
It's like exposure to Asenold has suddenly made him go and be
like a very reliable commentator out of nowhere.
LIKE FACTS FACTS FACTS FACTS OVER and over again. He's like DJ
A. We have been dragged into having to do the same to keep things
even Stevens cuz if they're going to jerryman we say we we're
not going to do it on principle then they just win everything
period as far as the I can see.
In a very weird way, once the other side starts cheating, in
order to make it more fair, you also have to start cheating.
Once they start being insane to keep it fair, you also have to
be equally insane in the opposite direction. Like, it's the only
way to do it. And again, he flips it and pretends like it's the
Democrats who are totally unhinged and that made the Republicans
radicalized. Get the out of here. also making it seem like um
you know
like Republicans are put upon to have to condemn a Republican
group chat where they were like loving
like that should be easy. It should be a low bar, bro. But to
them it's not. >> You have all these conservatives that
are saying this crazy stuff and there's never a point of moral
author. >> We got
I can't believe there's not a single Chudlogic subscriber in
here who's ready to act. Oh, wait. No, it's a local one. You
can't use it globally, right? [__] That's too bad.
Or that, you know, any liberal can have when you're the one justifying,
you know, shutting down a >> dude, they should put that
I don't know why he made that a non-global emote. That's crazy
to me. >> a college or you're the one justifying being
violent to an officer or you're the one justifying uh you know,
destroying property, somebody's car, something like that. They
all got blacklisted and fired from their jobs. Yes. But I I understand
that structurally, but that doesn't matter. It doesn't matter
what happened to them. What matters is how the public perceives
it. And I think that this is continuing to become the case. I
think that any conservative at this point should totally stop
purity testing because leftwing people don't purity test themselves.
And if brother you guys ran Roy Moore, can we just do the Roy
Moore thing? How how where do you have to go beyond the Roy Moore
thing? Bro, people don't talk about Roy Moore enough and the
fact that like Trump put him forward as a candidate. They actually
don't. That Democrats should never have let that go. If if Trump
was willing to nominate Roy Moore, how the [__] he
trust him with the Epstein files?
That's That's like all you need to be That should be all you
have to say. Okay. Talk about Roy Moore trying to get 14 year
olds in the mall at like 60.
Oh my god. The extent to which this guy has no idea what he's
talking about. It's like he just got into politics 7 seconds
ago. Like literally just 7 seconds ago, HE WAS LIKE, "HUH? POLITICS?
WHAT'S THAT? I HAVE OPINIONS on it. What is this? You don't know
what you're talking about. You know you don't know what you're
talking about." That's the thing that gets me is I know he knows.
He doesn't know what the [__] he's talking about.
You allow other people to create the optics for you. All you're
doing is you're allowing your enemy to define how you lose. >> Mark
Robinson was funny. Okay, don't compare him to Roy Moore and
Hershel Walker. Mark Robinson was funny.
And basically, you can see how they have no problem voting for
Jay Jones, right? This is a guy that like fantasized about uh
you know, his political opponent's >> He wasn't Are you
That's a lie. You're lying. You're lying. He said like three
people are in an elevator.
pole pot and his and my Republican opponent. What do you And
you only have two bullets. What do you do with the two bullets?
And he says both go in his opponent. That's obviously a [__]
joke.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. He also said some [__]
about his kids. Okay, Kyle.
Kyle. Kyle. Kyle. He said some crazy.
You can't pretend you I think he said something along the lines
of like, "Oh, I wouldn't I wouldn't feel bad if something happened
to the uh it was some [__] like that." Okay, it was
like a wild wild thing to say.
I don't know why he's pretending it wasn't. And the the core
of the joke is this is how evil these Republicans are. That's
the joke, right? So, oh, he wants to No, he doesn't. And by the
way, everybody knows that. The right knows that. Is it edgy as?
Absolutely. Was it private and not meant to go public?
But he doesn't actually want to kill his opponent. And by the
way, that's why he [__] won. And thank [__]
god he did. Hold on, Kyle.
Hold on, Kyle. Kyle,
we got to be real, Kyle. Don't we, Kyle? Don't we got to be real
here, Kyle? Oh, this is not Hold on.
Oh, nothing's going to work. Can I get something that's not paid?
Can I Can I get this these texts,
dude? Can I I just I just need the text, please. Thank you.
Right here. W USA9
is going to give us the text. Okay, so this is the two bullets
one, but there are more. Close the ad.
There are more of these.
Okay, somebody link me because I'm not finding them.
I don't know why I didn't just go search Twitter. That's where
I got to go. Hold
Oh, this is not even remotely the same thing. The hell?
Give me a sec,
dude. Google,
they've really up search in some ways, man. It's very annoying.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. There's an I point blank asked you more than
three times and you dug in. You meant it. I honestly am questioning
a lot today. I mean, do I think Todd and Jennifer are evil? Yeah.
Uh and that they're bleed breeding little fascists. Yes.
Jay, please stop.
If those guys die before me, I will go to their funerals to pick
up on their graves, send them out a wash in
You were talking about hopping gen hoping Jennifer Gilbert's
children would die. Yes. I've told you this before. Only when
people feel pain personally do they move on policy. That's the
one right there. You told me you were hoping their kids would
die. Yeah. So, he's basically saying I hope they get probably
shot in mass shooting event, right? Mass casualty event. Okay.
Kyle
really stretching that this didn't happen that Asal is making
it up. Okay,
this it's pretty clear.
Wait, did do you remember when you said you hoped this woman's
kids would die? Yes. And I stand on business on that is an insane
response because guess what? It's the exact opposite of what
edgy as the joke is. This is how
three people are in an
He knows he doesn't know what the [__] he's talking
about. You're allowing your enemy to define how you lose. >> Just
watch the whole thing. >> Basically, you can see how they
have no problem voting. >> That's not fantasizing about
them,
>> Okay, Porter Beller. It is not literally fantasizing
about them.
It is
wishing their deaths in a non non- like encouraging way, non
inciting way. It is it's definitely something that is like not
a part of political decorum. It's pretty far outside the norm.
for Jay Jones, right? This is a guy that like fantasized about
uh you know his political opponent's children. >> He wasn't
Are you That's a lie. You're lying. You're lying. He said like
three people are in an elevator.
Pull pot. I feel like what Asmin Gold said is way closer to the
truth than what Kyle is saying.
It's like not even close between them. Kyle's pretending that
it's totally insane to feel like he wanted those kids dead. to
feel like he was was like praying on those kids' downfall
and his and my rep. Yeah, Asmin's framing is less dishonest than
Kyle's Republican opponent. What do you And you only have two
bullets. What do you do with the two bullets? And he says both
go in his opponent. That's obviously a joke. And the the core
of the joke is this is how evil these Republicans are. That's
the joke, right? So he wants to No, he doesn't. And by the way,
everybody knows that. The right knows that. Is it edgy as [__]
Absolutely. Was it uh I will say
uh
no I think I think Asmin Gold's closer to like correct here.
I feel like Asmin Gold is definitely going to respond to this
tomorrow. We'll get to watch the Asmin Gold reaction where he's
like he'll he'll go, "Oh, I'll just go over this."
He'll probably even say, "Well, is that is that like fantasizing?"
No, but he definitely says it's like fine. He he he's thinking
about it a little bit private and not meant to go public,
but he doesn't actually want to kill his opponent. And by the
way, that's why he won. And um actually, he didn't fantasize
about their kids. He fantasized about their kids getting killed.
And there's a big difference there.
Thank God he did because guess what? It's the exact opposite
of what you're saying, Asmin Gold. Finally, Democrats have gotten
it and woken up. This is the only way forward for us because
Trump made this. By the way,
I'd still vote for that guy as an H over a Republican. [laughter]
I literally don't care. I'm sorry. That's like an awful statement.
He shouldn't be He shouldn't be running, but
no you like I'm not voting against that guy in a in an election.
I'm still going to vote for that guy. Okay. I said sorry. It's
very easy, very simple.
Bar's way bar is way different than that. But politics,
the rule of the day, he made it like this. Let's remember. Let's
remember. Here is what Trump and and MAGA here's what they've
referred to Democrats as during the Trump era. The enemy within.
Scum, terrorists, vermin, radical, lunatics, demonic, evil, fascist,
Marxist, communist, garbage, the enemy of the people, treasonous,
animals,
low lives.
This is how they talk about and some of them I assume are nice
>> about us and then finally when we go okay bet these
are the new rules fine we'll play by those rules too now you
whine and cry and moan no get the out of here get the out of
compare what Obama has called Republicans or what Biden has called
Republicans to what Trump has called Democrats it is night and
day you get you know buttoned up uh civility decorum professional
presidents from Biden and Obama when it comes to their language
visa v the other side. But Trump, no. He's throwing haymakers
left and right. And like I said, finally the Democratic reaction
to that is, okay, yeah, Jay Jones, fine to we're totally fine
with him. And now you want to cry and now you want to [__]
and now you want to moan. Well, maybe you should have thought
about that when Trump was calling us the enemy within and [__]
terrorists. Maybe if you policed your own side a little more,
we wouldn't have gotten to the point where Jay Jones would be
the standard bear. If you're going to vote for that person and
you're not going to have people withdraw their nominations from
them, well then I don't I don't want to hear from you about how
bad it is that somebody said something bad in a group chat. It
it it's just absolutely incredible. It's amazing. I
uh I think it's fair to say you guys shouldn't virtue signal
about the group chat with Jay Jones,
but it is Yeah, the decorum stuff is all on Republicans like
100%. It's all on Trump really specifically.
So,
I I do think that people going, "Oh, you can't have those people
in the group chat like making those jokes."
I I don't know. Whatever.
I think it says a lot about the Republican party. It's like horrible
PR to deal with. But that's the that's the bargain you make,
right? If you want to say, "Oh, we're not going to purity test.
We're not going to have standards. We're going to go low. Then
we're going to go lower." Right? When you when you have that
kind of attitude, you do deal with the bad PR.
That's the way it is. What the [__] is
>> Oh my god.
>> That's uh >> PSG. LGD. Oh, wait. PSG. Paris St.
Germaine. I I said LGD cuz I watch Dota. >> Um PSG.
>> Oh, Oslo. Oh,
why did I think Chelsea?
>> That's Barcelona. >> I'm sorry. I'm done with
this. is already gay. Soccer gross. Okay, I think I'm done with
the Kyle video as well. He's going to rant about Asmin Golden
Trump for a little longer.
Not as good as I thought. I did want to get to this this uh this
theory video from Carl Benjamin. One Carl Benjamin.
See what he has to
That is Chelsea. Yeah. Hold on.
Chelsea symbol. I thought it was a blue lion. Oh, what the
It is Chelsea.
Oh, wait. Was he him up? Is that the joke? Is that That's the
joke that is that he them up. Okay. Oh, I see. I see. It was
Chelsea. I got it right. Damn.
His tweets are better. Tweets are his strong suit. Okay. Well,
I think this guy is he's rightwing. I don't think he's like totally
I think his opinions are bad. There's got to be a way to say
like his opinions are bad, but he's not totally. Also,
he kind of looks like I see something here. If you if you take
away like some of the facial features, I see like Nick Rakita,
like face shape, facial hair
uh hairstyle. There's like a Nick Rakita vibe to this except
it's just a totally different face.
Right. Like I'm I'm not saying the face is close at all. I'm
saying if you like blurred the face out entirely, you just put
Nick Rita's face on this without the gray. Maybe
>> White with beard. No, it's like head shape. It's hair.
It's everything. >> You seem to understand why Nick Fuentes
is popular. And so I thought I would record this video to explain.
Now I'm too old.
>> Nick Fuentes is popular. Is Dick Quentes popular in
the same way that Brexit is popular? I don't want to I don't
want to paint by numbers the analysis that way,
but it is like a similar thing where people who are like kind
of provocators can do this I'm speaking truth to power thing.
There's some there's there's like a combination of resentment
of the country changing lack of economic progress or economic
growth in your area. these things fuel like, "Oh, I need an other
to point to." And when other people won't when other people won't
blame the other for you or when like when you have like real
hard times and everybody tells you you're like crazy, everything's
great.
That is what I think leads to like something like a Fentes or
the Brexit type of movement. It is quite similar like the I think
the ingredients you need to have Brexit happen or have Nick Fuentes
rise to get the level of popularity he's gotten to very similar
a fan of Nick Fuentes,
but I can understand why young men like him. I can understand
what his appeal is to them. And I just want to explain it because
a lot of people approach Nick Fuentes along ideological lines.
They say, "But he said this about Israel. He said this about
women. He said this about black people." And therefore, and it's
like, okay, yes, he talks a lot. His job, his career is as a
professional talker. And when you are
small on the internet, it's very easy to gain attention by saying
quite radical
in order to attract an audience.
You'll notice that in recent years he's moderated himself because
he has found his audience. He has uh polished his craft, should
we say. And all of the clips that you see, he's moderated himself.
There's not been like a it's not been like a
uh
he's moderated in some ways, but it's almost like just avoiding
certain
In other ways, he's not moderated. I think I don't know how much
he's really moderated his positions almost at all. In some ways,
he has, especially if he's on a different platform. On his own
platform, he still says fairly offensive [__] all
the time. He straight up doubled down on like cool like yesterday
or the day before.
Like I I don't know. People say, "Oh, he's moderated a ton."
It's No, not >> Of him saying the most radical things are
quite old now. They're from a few years back. >> Yeah.
But that's laziness on the part of the people who are getting
the clips, right? That's the sad thing is I think you could get
almost all of those opinions Nick expressed that they're like
trying to get him with. I think those are all old clips, but
not because he's moderated, but because they're just too lazy
to go find the new clips.
The new clips exist. I've seen tons of clips of him being super
racist to people, to racist to everybody. I've seen him spouting
all kinds of crazy
This is actually not terribly surprising and not really very
interesting to what is actually happening because again compl
condemning him on ideological lines that's great but you know
that's very easy to do. anyone's capable of doing that. But the
problem with the normicons as they do this is not only do they
set themselves up against the next
they blind themselves to that generation's problems because really
they've kind of failed to update their own ideological software.
The normie conservatives who are about my age, the sort of, you
know, elder millennial, younger gen X and older
need to understand that we grew up in much more homogeneous societies
than the zoomers are. And you think you won the argument against
the left.
So for the first bit, America in 1990
when I became what you know 10 11 years old and you know uh the
the '9s generally were an absolutely amazing decade to become
a teenager in
a very vibrant, fun, full of life. There was technology but the
technology hadn't taken over. So it was genuinely a wonderful
transition period to have grown up in and to have matured into
um in America.
He's hardcore overthinking
>> The non-Hispanic thought population was
>> And that's with the historic black population
uh next to it about again 10 13% something like that. Um so you
had what was a very homogeneous society. And this wasn't a society
that was entirely um well spaced either. You had areas of America
that were historically far more diverse, but the rest of America
was basically historically white. And so
that has gone down to now 55%
non-Hispanic white as of this year. And of course, predictions
for the future, if trends continue, mean that that's just going
to go down further and further and further until white people
are a minority compared to the non-white people in the United
States. So this whether you like it or not has generally discredited
Buckleyite conservatism.
This has rendered its arguments out of date because the assumption
of the Martin Luther King colorblind society was always predicated
on a kind of invisible understanding
and again the sort of presupposition that everyone around will
basically hold. Uh, I don't think I don't think Buckley's the
guy that Counterpoints references. Who does he reference?
Oh, I've read part of this. I've read like half of one of this
guy's books. Blake, right? Blake.
Blake. I think it's Blake. Burke. Burky and conservatives. Yes.
>> Hold the same opin. >> Edund Burke, right? >> Opinion.
Well, in a highly diverse multicultural society where there is
no one overarching demographic that sets the agenda of the nation,
uh that's not true. It's not a true assumption that everyone
basically holds the same opinion and therefore the kind of colorblind
buckleyite conservatism can work. That paradigm has come to an
end because socially that's just not how things go. And then
you've got the >> Well, it's ah I don't know if that's
true.
Like a colorblind society doesn't work because it's never been
attempted. You could say it's like communism almost, right? The
whole point of a of a colorblind society is you don't have group
groups advocating against one another, right? Or against like
the majority group or anything.
You can't have groups of certain ethnicities that are allowed
to advocate on that ethnicity's behalf
and then other ethnicities can't. That wouldn't that's not a
colorblind society, right? Question of the sort of infinite regonomics
of eternal growth. Well, as we saw with Trump today,
the the American establishment is still on that
But I can't help but notice that that's come alongside his proposals
for 50-year mortgages because this is a system that is [laughter]
spiraling out of D. The 50-year mortgage is so insane.
the concept of a 50-year mortgage, like I thought I thought there
was going to be some cool Trump innovation there that like somehow
they'd keep the interest down, like it wouldn't just work mechanically
like other mortgages, like somehow there'd be some period backed
by the government in a way that made it like more likely you
get this mortgage paid out or something. But it's like But it's
like a 50-year mortgage where actually you just pay like triple
the original principal
for the house.
It's like wait what? Wait. Huh? Huh?
Control. It is actually making it more and more difficult for
the people born within it to get ahead using it. And this is
why so much of the left, the the Mandani faction of the left
have got a very strong argument in some ways on their economic
policies. Again, whether you agree with them or not, the argument
is persuasive. It is rhetorically effective and it is forming
a large coalition that is capable of winning elections. And >> ah
this is where so it's got a period here. It's got a shelf life,
right? if this if this doesn't work eventually it's going to
stop winning elections.
So I don't know there's like some concern about what kind of
society's left over if there if if America has to have a clash
with white identitarianism.
I sure hope I sure hope whichever side wins wins quickly is would
be my thought on it. Okay.
Cuz I swear like if it's um there's like some prolonged thing
where there's like terrorist attacks and stuff and then white
people are like no longer majority in the US or anywhere. There's
like this animosity. Oh yo. >> So if you are a Buckleyite
Reaganite
you can't form an effective counterargument because it is your
position that brought us to this point. You are offering more
of the same. And actually more of the same doesn't seem very
appealing.
Um, I don't know about chimpanzees, evil Johnny Bravo, but I've
told you about the the brain study, right? Where people where
it's just like labels on a monitor. Be sure like even a very
arbitrary label, you still have some like
oh, what is it? Like you have a sympathetic pain response to
people who have like flipped a coin the same way you have like
10 minutes ago that if like they flip tails, you flip tails.
It's like if you see yourself in them, right, you have a sympathetic
response to their pain, to their suffering.
in a way that you don't if they have nothing in common with you.
And so there is some element there that like yeah color is obviously
the most easily visible thing. You can't really hide it.
And so a tattoo I would imagine would work the same way. I just
don't know if chimps do the same kind of segregation.
To the young people who are growing up now actually they're looking
at their own civilization and saying well this isn't terribly
good. and they can see videos and movies and just historical
footage from just 30 years ago when the civilization was so much
better because things were different.
And then you've got these other aspects to it which are not necessarily
Enoch Pal is a hated figure by the British liberal establishment,
but they can't deny that what he said about demographics was
true, but also the consequences the the the
political and moral consequences of that, which is about who
holds the whip hand, that is who holds demographic,
political and thereby legal authority over the nation. Now again
during the Buckleyike consensus I mean America would have been
about 90%
white non-Hispanic during his era and so it's easy to think that
fundamentally everyone thinks the same as you because you are
surrounded by people who think the same as you and who are not
in society they decide to embrace Nick
understand that's like an insane thing to say hero is overdosing
just so you
They should simply Why didn't we Oh my god. I Heroes overdosing
has it. Why didn't they just make it so like racism is bad? Has
anybody tried to think racism is bad? Does Has Flint ever heard
this one? Hey Nick, did you know that racism bad? Actually, guys,
racism bad.
Racism is bad. Racism is now cured.
Simply making it so being a minority isn't a negative in society.
Wow.
>> Operating in a divergent eth. >> Why hadn't anybody
thought of like getting rid of racism? That's crazy.
basically all the same. And so what you >> Yeah, I bet
you could do it easily.
A bunch of places do it really easily. It's by having 90% the
same ethnicity there have >> is the kind of self- selecting
political plurality of party politics. However, when you're in
a country that's 55%
white, non-Hispanic,
what you end up with is much more uh ethnically focused party
politics. Uh parties are in fact a bit of a luxury that you can't
really afford. You have to vote with your ethnic uh interest
and in your community. This is what we are seeing of course with
Mandami and with the Somalians and various other um the Mexicans
as well. So it's it's one of those things where
this kind the sort of 20th century politics I'm afraid has run
its course because it was undermined by the left and this leading
us on to you think you won the arguments with the left. It's
like you didn't right you didn't win the arguments from the left.
You may have had it so that from your own position you failed
to lose but that doesn't guarantee the victory because whilst
you were fighting on one front holding the line on this particular
issue the left was
encircling you and completely outflanking you and that's what
they've done with mass immigration but they've also done this
in various other ways. I mean like the the complete lack >> realize
those places are hyper racist,
not to most people >> of proper [laughter] punishment for
certain communities, certain ethnic minorities in America is
just crazy. Like the the the crazy amount of
of permissiveness that the state shows to people of certain communities.
So, racial identitarianism didn't exist in the UK like before
2020.
Be serious.
Be serious right now. Be be
Racial identitarianism didn't exist in the UK like before 2020.
>> So, they are complete re repeat offenders. Repeat reoffenders.
Repeat reoffenders until they're just murdering people in the
streets.
This is wild, right? But what I mean like the for example a great
case of this is Daniel Penny like oh my god like I watched the
events with Daniel Penny and was just kind of horrified by the
response. But I mean there are so many examples. Just pick one,
you know, just pick an example. What was the the one where the
black kid murdered the white kid with a knife in the uh sports
field and then raised something like a million dollars from the
black community because he had stabbed a white boy, right? like
this. This resonates with these straight white young men because
it doesn't make sense that their own society should be so stacked
against them.
It speaks to a profound unfairness in American society that predates
these young men and that they were born and raised into
not knowing anything different, but being aware that at some
point in the past it wasn't like this. and for some reason their
parents and grandparents allowed this to be given away.
In addition to this, there has also been the non-stop campaign
from the left to attack white people and specifically straight
white men for being white people and straight white men. Right
now, this should never have been acceptable. And you thought
you won this war, but you didn't. you and like I said, you held
your line, but demographic change
has in fact just
made your front irrelevant in the conversation because all of
these groups that now make up 45% of the United
This was way less about human psychology
and way more about like his his interpretation of like it is
about human psychology. I just feel like it's way easier to identify
what Fuentes does that makes him popular than like I guess the
way demographic changes sort of pressure this nearing minority
or plurality status party or ethnicity to like reach out to more
extremes because they don't feel defended. I I think that's where
he's going with this. I think that's where he's going to end
up. Right. They don't have any prohibition on
considering themselves in an ethnic manner and advancing their
own interests in said way. They don't have any prohibition on
that at all. And so once again, you're looking at the unfairness
of American society and saying, "Well,
I'm sorry, straight white men, you're just going to have to suck
it up." It should never have been acceptable to have had attack
after attack after attack on white people, straight people, white
men, straight white men in any
But it carried on and the left therefore dedicated themselves
to stripping the authority, the moral authority away from white
men. And for some reason, the conservatives couldn't bear to
assert that moral authority on those same grounds.
And so the argument was eventually lost. You said, "Well, I I'm
an MLK Buckley. I don't see color."
your opponent does. And if you don't address it on those grounds,
then you don't actually win that argument. What?
So, here's the thing. When you make a video like this,
I think there's a certain kind of person.
This is like really aerodite coded to me where he has to say
like MLK Buckleyite. Why don't you just talk about like the attributes?
Find like a way to define it early on and then either use your
own definition or or just describe it like as you're saying it.
I really really don't like people who have to use like specific
definitions even if they're technically correct in videos meant
for like the average person. I think it's like really ineffective.
I think it's just rhetorically ineffective every time.
Right. He could just say like colorblind meritocracy type people,
they're losing like right like the the colorblind people, they've
lost. Hey, you're color blind, but your opponent's racist.
Hey, you're you're basically fighting with a principle that prevents
you from being able to beat this person. You're fighting with
a principle that is working against you.
it it like all delivers the same message and you can have this
theory underlying it. I just I don't know maybe maybe you guys
think differently, but I just feel like he's doing a lot of the
jargon that is or he's using a lot of jargon that just makes
it it obiscates like his meaning and stuff. Unless you can do
that translation instantly, I don't mind it. I just I feel like
if anything, Trump's show me that this is not good. And I think
really good communicators
will figure out how to get past this. How to how to take something
that they've got in a very technical sense, in a very academic
sense, they've got this idea and then how do I dumb it down to
so the average person who's unfamiliar can understand it and
he doesn't feel the need to do that, which is weird cuz then
he also is like the every man I'm fighting for the middle class
of of the UK.
It kind of cuts against like who he's trying to be. He's like
got a Flintto's problem, but he's not as funny. He's not as young,
he's not as charismatic, and he's even
It kind of makes me wonder how he's so successful,
right? The the answer to are straight white men fundamentally
immoral is say no. Straight white men are not fundamentally immoral.
In fact, straight white men are the source of a great deal of
morality in American society. They are the ones that are cleaning
the sewers, that are
fixing the buildings, that are making society work. These themselves
are moral acts and they should have been defended as the moral
acts of straight white men. But you didn't do it. And don't get
me wrong, I was just as guilty. I was like basically a buckleite
liberal about 10 years ago. I was in the same position, but I
have done a lot of thought on this and you haven't. you have
refused to change as the world has changed around you. So anyway,
combined with all of this has been the demographic shift in the
United States. You know what Ben Shapiro called the Browning
of America that he doesn't care about. Well, I'm sorry, Ben,
but a lot of people actually do care about it and it does have
consequences. Like you were spuring on about Mandani, but he
is a product of that demographic shift. And so the left combined
their moral attack on white men with mass immigration to ensure
that they would have a huge and growing consistent con constituency
that could be relied upon to also have interests aligned against
the white man. So they would they would have an incentive to
take resources away from the white majority of America and take
it for themselves. So it's not surprising that straight white
men, Zuma straight white men who have been saddled with this
are actually not happy about this situation. They're not happy
and also they feel vulnerable. They they are looking for a way
to defend themselves in the coming world and the present world
that liberalism has brought about for them. They can see that
they have lost something.
the thing >> that's closer that people can see that
ultimately it's going to come down to
something like this
what if you know white men in the US decide at some point like
collectively as a block 90% of white men decide
actually we should have just tried to take over the world when
we were 90% of the population here we should have just tried
to take over the world like it we're our our quality of life's
going down the average person here is like not having a great
time. Why do we go for like colorblind egalitarianism? Hasn't
served us at all?
I just It would be concerning if that ever happens. Usually the
thing that fights against that is the state of the world, like
the state of your life being such that your life's way too good
to [__] up,
right? At some point that goes away. I don't think you're anywhere
near that point yet. I think I think people mostly get whipped
into a frenzy online and they're like, "Oh yeah, I have a phone
and like food so that I can just sit here online posting on Twitter
all day." Your life's like not quite as bad as you thought. It's
maybe not great, but it's not quite as bad as you >> Thing
is, that thing is hard to define because it's not material and
it can't be quantified, but it made their parents and grandparents
world completely different to their own. And that thing they've
lost is a sense of possession. They no longer possess their country
in the way that previous generations did. They look at their
country as something that belongs to other people and not themselves.
And this is a collective sense of possession. This is to say
it is collectively theirs and not the property of other nations.
And of course, they've been discriminated against expressly for
their whole lives. Right? They see themselves in a no-win situation.
If they keep quiet about what they can perceive happening around
them and the fact that there is no light at the end of the tunnel,
they are on the road to ruin.
But if they speak out, they get cancelled by the feminized HR
moms who Okay, we need to stop with this one now. Okay, this
was this was the this is a different kind of persecution that
white men used to go over or used to go through. Okay, you were
like, "Hey,
a lot of brown people around right now." used to get fired. Now
you get a podcast. Okay. So, let's let's just acknowledge where
we've gone, where we've come from, where we've gotten to. Now
you get a podcast when you say that. It's way different. We're
in a way different place. All right. We shouldn't do the victimization
of like, oh, now you just have to go to HR if you ever say anything
uncou. I don't think it's like that. I think we've gotten to
a point where, oh, we're having a very different conversation.
The pendulum has swung back away from that super that hyperwoke
culture. Okay. to pretend we're still in that to use that. I
mean, it's dishonest. I guess people are going to do it. Just
won the Republicans an >> Run all of the corporations and
make sure that they oversee the corporate culture of the United
States. They get they get cancelled for this. And so it's like,
right, okay, that's a that's a pretty a pretty pretty horrible
position to be in. It's a bit of a hobson's choice, isn't it?
Like, do you just carry on to your own destruction or do you
just destroy yourself immediately?
Hard choice. hard choice.
I think I know which one I've chosen though, obviously.
and over all of this is of course still the reign of political
correctness.
And this the the problem that the buckling conservative
boomers have is that they themselves are politically correct,
which is why they didn't challenge any of this on the terms by
which the left would present it. They themselves are part of
the politically correct orthodoxy. They have been the acceptable
containment measure that the left has has allowed to continue
to exist whilst they outflanked you. And so to defeat the reign
of political correctness, it demands people who speak heresies
whether they are true or not. It does not matter whether you
think the things that Nick Fantas are true or that you think
they're untrue. It doesn't matter in the slightest. What matters
is the authority which holds down ideas whose time has come.
That authority has to be broken. And so that's why you get someone
like Nick Fuentes being incredibly popular. I mean, he's been
cancelled forever off of everything. He was on no fly list at
one point like the he and he's only like 27. He has he has been
through the ringer. He has really been through it
and he's still going. And so that >> uh I asked the DJer
a question. Surely they'll answer, right? We'll see. Turns him
into a kind of Robin Hood figure. People find that appealing.
And I'm sorry, but he does have some virtues of his own, right?
He is funny. He is lucid. He is able to speak clearly and engagingly
about the subjects. Even if you don't like what he says, he's
still a good communicator. And to be honest with you, he is funny.
Like I see a bunch of the clips going around, especially the
ones where he's >> Bro, this is like this was the gayest
thing I've ever seen. This guy just click baited me into listening
to his philosophy on buckle conservatism
for 15 minutes and barely talked about Fuentes at all. I understand
that they're connected. I understand it's not like the a total
bait and switch, but it feels like a 90% bait and switch. Nothing
about how Fentes is unique in some way other than that he's funny.
has been edited into like a restaurant or something and it's
some insanely racist rant. Uh, and they are funny. They are genuinely
funny and I can see why they're popular. I mean, I personally
have plenty of criticisms of him for being a gay Zoomer, but
the Zuma men didn't make themselves.
They are the product of the feminist system that the conservatives
permitted to exist and form them into that thing that they are
now. We collectively ought to have been more concerned with their
well-being, but we relied on a series of assumptions that didn't
hold up
in the new demographic reality. We we assumed that men and women
are just interchangeable as teachers. Turns out that's not true.
If you want a feminized workplace, habits at the 75% of the teachers
are women. And you won't get the kind of masculine energy counterbalancing
the feminine energy. It's just it doesn't matter about the quality
of the teaching. What matters is the kind of the character of
the teaching itself,
>> bro. This was this was like the worst [__]
video. This was like the worst
How much time do we got left? We just wasted a lot on Sargon.
Nine subs away from another hour in the stream, guys. What do
we got? We got Lena still.
We got Lena. We've got
I'm not going to do more Candace right now. We're good on Candace
Vicon. We got Fuentes and Aiden.
We've got Oh, the Warren Smith stuff. I might fire up the Warren
Smith stuff. I think this is the good [__] right
now. I think this is really good [__]
by the way, I still maintain,
sorry, somebody's linking like some DG logs over here. I still
maintain there's like no proof that these people met up or that
anyone knew it. I I literally said it was like skits was why
we didn't talk about it when it happened and all of this. It
was just a really funny coincidence. Okay.
really funny coincidence that had to do with
Oh, where where was Aerodite on
August? Wait, was it 16th? I lost the date again. 15th 17th me.
Whatever.
It's just a weird It's a crazy coincidence, guys. I don't know
what to I don't know what else to think.
All right, let's do the Warren Smith stuff because I think that's
going to be
I'll pull up the video first and we'll see if that's going to
be interesting. And then I think so
I don't know for sure,
but I believe
that Warren Smith tried to do like an event. Okay, like a student
event.
So I was invited by Sam Richards to come down and talk to his
students. This is the same class I've made a number. >> I
invited a class of 500 students to confront me on absolutely
>> number of videos covering. We started having this conversation
after a remarkable class session the day after Charlie Kirk was
assassinated. I made a video covering that class and that's gotten
close to 4 million views. >> What is it about listening
to to students that's so intriguing?
because this is where those conversations are supposed to be
>> There were concerns around will the school try and shut
this down because there are concerns
that why would a school shut down Warren Smith isn't even like
racist or something. He's like got no crazy opinions at all.
Warren Smith's got absolutely zero crazy opinions. What does
he mean? Are they going to try to shut us down? >> What
if the student sees negative comments? I decided, you know what?
I will get in my car and drive down there and talk to them myself.
College is about you trying to become the person you could be.
It's one thing to stand in front of a a crowd of people. It's
another when there are potentially millions of people watching
you do it. If you don't think that has utility,
and many colleges don't. Why? It's easier for them not to do
this because there are risks. There are liabilities. There's
going to be the potential for hurt feelings. But you're all adults
as well. People your age are fighting wars. You vote. You should
be able to handle me comments. And we'll kind of get into some
of this tonight. >> Because I've made videos covering this
class. It's only fair that you all should have a chance to challenge
me on anything that you want >> cuz I've made videos covering
some of you. Please feel free to challenge me. >> So, the
first student raised their hand. Um, you said that you value
autonomy in your thought, but all you really do in your videos,
which you post nearly every day, is react to Joe Rogan podcast,
which doesn't really [laughter]
sound like individual thoughts of me. So, can you comment on
that? >> That's a challenge. >> Yeah. No, if we were
to look at now and then I will cover a Joe Rogan interaction.
The last one was Joe Rogan and Elon Musk. It [snorts] might be
I if we were to actually go through the numbers it's probably
more accurate like maybe twice a month. Um if there were it's
if there were more interesting exchanges I would definitely delve
into it. I don't know what I'm going to cover tomorrow. It's
there's interesting moves being made here. It might be on Joe
Rogan. It might not be.
>> Ago was a magician claiming to be able >> Wait,
what? What are the edits?
Hold on.
What are the edits going on here? This just jumped all over the
place.
That's not That's not the same as it
years ago was a magician claiming to be able to read people's
body.
>> Wait, what? Luckily, okay, hold on.
he also perhaps accidentally so published the full VA of this,
I believe. Give me a second.
Oh, no. Sorry, sorry, sorry. There's a there's a live stream
from the class from another another channel's got the full live
stream here. Okay, we can watch the full
uncut live stream. I kind of want to watch all of some of Warren's
representations of things before jumping into the the actual
live stream here. >> Audio language and deduce a pin number.
You're right. He did appear on Joe Rogan a few months ago, but
that video Joe didn't It doesn't matter if Joe's in it or not,
but he could be a magician. >> You create your own content,
but you don't really give your own like thought. At least from
what I've seen. I mean, granted, I only watched like a few minutes
out of each of your videos while I've been sitting here. Uh,
but I have gone through like, you know, a year or so uh through
of the videos and I've seen like the titles of them. You don't
you ne you don't necessarily like give your own thought.
You don't you don't really, you know, comment on anything
that's, you know, of substance that other people haven't mentioned
themselves.
And this was off to a lackluster start. There's an obvious flaw
there. The professor pointed it out. >> But, bro, you said
you said
the professor saved him. Is that what happened? Hold on. I now
I'm going to go back. I Let's find it. So, hold on. What was
it? Um, anything of substance yourself.
[snorts]
Here we go. Here's where it says >> that other people haven't
mentioned themselves while I've been sitting here. >> There's
interesting moves being made here. It might be on Joe Rogan.
It might not be. But you you What was the second part of that?
You said, "So, I'm not I don't have full autonomy because I'm
covering Joe Rogan too much." Well, you create your own content,
but you don't >> He cuts He cuts a lot of the stuff, doesn't
he? >> Really give your own >> What is this transcript
[__] you do? I open a tab. I open like show more
and you go down to show transcript. This is literally just built
into the YouTube
>> Like thought, at least from what I've seen, I mean,
granted, I only watched like a few minutes out of each of your
videos while I've been sitting here. Uh but I have gone through
like you know a year or so uh through of the videos and I've
seen like the titles of them. You don't you ne you don't necessarily
like give your own thought. You don't you don't really you know
comment on anything
that's you know of substance that other people haven't mentioned
>> Bro why do you you just react Warren. Warren you just
react all the
>> Warren come on man. So I don't I don't really consider
you an influencer but really a commentator. >> That's I
don't want I I would like to not think of myself as an influencer
>> Call himself an influencer either. >> No, but
if look at cuz I'm I try and when I'm watching these dynamics
I'm trying to identify the moves. >> Can I just ask you
to back up to because I want Can you just say what you're doing
because not everyone would know what what are you trying >> I'm
making it up as I go.
Yeah. If I see something interesting, I'm like,
>> Try. And when I'm watching these dynamics, I'm trying
to identify the >> Can I just ask you to back up to because
I want Can you just say what you're doing? Cuz not everyone would
know what What are you trying? >> I'm making it up as I
go.
>> Yeah. If I >> Bro, no wonder it's edited the way
it is.
Dude,
this is actually crazy
that he edits it down to still.
He edits out like all of the fumbling, just tries to keep stuff
in. By the way, his response in his actual edited video is that
the professor comes in and
I see something interesting. I'm like, "Oh, this is the move
here. I see a logical flaw here. This is why at some points I
I this is where I think that logic is wrong. So the last video
for example which was of this class, it was talking about the
flaws of equity specifically and I'm I don't think Sam interjected
those arguments if you watch that video the argument being made
are the points where I where I disagree with
>> So you're can I just further clarification? So you're
saying
>> saying I mean why wouldn't you just say yeah my channel's
mostly critique on other people. I don't do a lot of my own positive
stuff. I mostly poke holes and things. That's the way it is.
That's the kind of content that people want to see. That's what
my channel became.
That's that's what it is.
You don't have to like why why get self-conscious? Yeah. My channel's
mostly critique.
Critique or like commentary. That's that's what my channel is.
But he just gets like self-conscious and he's like trying to
explain. No, no, no. There there's like arguments I'm making.
No, no, no. I listen. I I'm just making it up as I go along.
>> Come on, man. >> Anything you could possibly see
in the online space, you would say you something could stimulate
a thought. >> Yeah. Two videos ago was a magician claiming
to be able to read people's body language and deduce a pin number.
You're right. He did appear on Joe Rogan a few months ago, but
that video Joe didn't It doesn't matter if Joe's in it or not,
but he could be a magician. It's thinking critically.
Yeah, it's it's I use the tag the art of thinking critically,
right? It's thinking for yourself. >> I think that one
of the things that this semester, for example, I decided that
I was going to do more was I was actually going to do more commentary.
In fact, what I was planning to do was on
I would
put some students over here on a table, like sit at a table,
and then >> cuz this guy's going to do commentary. Let's
go. >> I would talk about things and have them interject
with questions once in a while, but I was actually going to do
lots more commentary.
And then on Thursdays, I would do the classic thing where, you
know, have three students sit up in the front and ask them questions,
you know, but I never did that because I just don't I can't in
this space. I can't I just don't do the commentary. I do it during
my office hours on Wednesday afternoons, but I don't do it here.
And so one of the things I like about your videos is you like
drill down into like following the logic of people's arguments,
which for me is something I would like to do, but Warren's content
could almost be good. It could almost reach a bar. He's one of
these people who could almost reach the bar of passable commentary
if
it was in a stream on the fly actually making comments, right?
Like like it but it's edited. It's edited and put together, produced.
Dude, it is so
there's like nothing special there. There's nothing interesting
there.
>> I don't have time to do it. And I'm not going to do
it in this space because I'm not going to do that with students.
I'm not going to like break down people's
>> So that's also Thank you for that. Thank you. So please
please more of that because that's going to get into where we
were trying. >> I was just about to go there, >> right?
I I was just about to um because you're doing you're commenting
what and doing what we mostly don't do when we're in face toface
places but we do do in these online spaces where we comment directly
on what we like and don't like about what people say and do right
so that's unusual and rare for someone to do it just in voice
and so so >> it's great no it shouldn't be rare I mean
I'm used to used to it because I am [clears throat] so to me
that's not rare >> so we want to talk about this whole
phenomenon of commenting and and what does that mean and what
does it produce and what should it produce and so do you want
to just kick kick anything off from >> should what produce
>> the commenting this this this reaction to content to
people to behavior
>> yeah it that for me is feedback you know I'm I'm people
say don't read the the comments but I do think it has
a lot of utility honestly And so yeah,
Warren
Warren's better than this, isn't it? [laughter] >> Right.
I was just about to um cuz you're doing you're commenting
and doing what we mostly don't do when we're in face tof face
places but we do do in these online spaces where we comment directly
on what we like and don't like about what people say and do right
so that's unusual and rare for someone to do it just in voice
and so so >> it's great no it shouldn't be rare I mean
I'm used to used to it because I am so to me that's not rare
>> so we want to talk about this whole phenomenon of commenting
and and what does that mean and what does it produce and what
should it produce and and so do you want to just kick kick anything
off from that
>> should it produce uh what does it produce oh it produces
snarking copious amounts of snarking okay nothing but snarking
when you really
when you really think about it okay nothing but snarking he's
like he's
I'm not even joking by the way I do think like primarily commentary
not talking to people face to face. It does lead to you being
like overly critical, like overly callous, overly antisocial.
So, probably it should be mixed in with actual
speaking to people, right? Just being overly critical all of
the time. It probably leads to some bad things. There probably
should be some sort of like etiquette for it, some sort of observed
etiquette. You look at like YouTube comments, they're usually
quite biting, quite cutting. It's mostly criticism. Maybe there
should be something there to like more reflect how humans actually
I don't know. I don't I just don't bother with a lot of the back
and forth.
Like I have people who comment who are critical in the chat.
I don't know. It's just like a different thing.
YouTube comments are always chill and well thought out. Yeah,
sure. Yeah, sure. I'll I'll go along with this totally insane
thing you just said, Ry. Why not?
I'm more offended you if you call me a snarker instead of just
an [__] Oh, I'm I'm just joking about the snarking.
It's like a lot of internet commentary does lead to snarking,
right? The the disconnect from people. But here's the thing that
nobody wants to grapple with there. Okay. A lot of snarking is
accurate. The most prolific a logs. If somebody has just hours
and hours a day to study your behavior,
unfortunately, they're going to have accurate reads on your behavior
a lot of the time,
right? Like if somebody just watches another like another streamer
or something all day and especially from like a critical place,
they're going to have predictable like they're going to recognize
patterns in your behavior that do exist.
It's going to happen, right? So ultimately, if you could find
a way to harness that thing, you've you've basically somebody
watching you watching your game tape all the time, you should
be able to harness that in some way and get better, right? You
would think one would one would suppose.
Anyway, I just wanted to try to get my own answer out there instead
of just letting Warren flounder on his own. Okay. I see him floundering
on his own and I'm like, "Oh, I'll try to throw an answer out
there so I can not just make fun of Warren without actually trying
to answer myself." >> Should what produce? >> But
the commenting this this this reaction to content, to people,
to
>> Yeah, it that for me is feedback. you know, I'm I'm
people say don't read the the comments, but I do think it has
a lot of utility, honestly. And so, yeah, I've seen that comment
will pop up, you know, and there's parts of me that's like, >> wait,
hang on, though. But, bro, you
>> dude, what the
Warren just got cut off. Warren was about to cook. This guy just
cut him off. Bro, bro, you just said that's a 60-year-old man,
65-year-old man talking to like a 19-year-old. >> You said
I just scrolled through a few of your You said You said I just
scrolled through a few of your videos right now.
>> That's like what in like five minutes. in 5 minutes
you already made a comment by just scrolling through some videos
right now and they're like yo yo yo yo
dog you can't make a comment after that what you did which is
good that's fine but that comment is like the comment that you
that we leave online to some video like people watch 30 seconds
of one of my videos and then they make a >> I'm starting
to understand why this guy thought Warren was a good figure to
bring into class >> comment about it I'm This guy saw Warren,
he's like, "Oh my god, this guy's profound. I need to get him
to come talk to my class."
>> 30 seconds. >> And so, and this is getting into
not only the conversation we were having, but and this isn't
just about you, so >> Yeah. No, it's
he can handle it. [laughter] >> But what is the one of
the things that we want to just be thinking about is what is
the difference between social behavior in person and social behavior
online? And what does that mean? And what is that doing to us
now as humans that we have this place where we're so direct and
so willing to say things that we would say don't even read people's
comments. But yet but yet in person
it's so rare that somebody says something directly to someone
or else it's a fight. Maybe that's part of the reason >> it's
not I really don't think it's a fight honestly. It shouldn't
it doesn't
>> it shouldn't bother me. I mean, it doesn't bother me.
>> Doesn't bother me because honestly, you're going to
detect that part where most of the time it is someone who's just,
no offense, but has watched a minute and and making an observation.
>> No, he didn't say a minute. He said the couple minutes
of a lot of your videos. He was like, I've watched most of your
videos a couple minutes into Did he say I think he said your
videos I've watched a few I can only get a few minutes into your
videos, but he said he'd watched a >> And that's so you
could You're not going to take that personal and it's and it's
fine. And it's not going to we're all adults. There's this this
does tie into how our conversation began where so after Charlie
Kirk made that video and
I shared my thoughts on there and um
this I don't want to blur the student came up to me right before
class and said like I gained a lot from those comments like I
I I don't that's her ch her mind might have changed. I don't
want to put her on the spot, but she was like that. Thank you
for [laughter] I I haven't grappled in it in that way. I think
that's an example of how this new technology has utility in education.
Listen, no, I get that from students who come up here and sometimes
they they stumble and they say something they wish they didn't
say or sometimes they just having an experience up here, but
they're always really thankful to have had the opportunity to
put themselves out there, man. And that's what that's what we're
doing in this world. Putting ourselves out there and what and
being willing to
hear other people's reflections on what it is that we think.
And man, there is nothing more valuable or powerful than that.
And like challenging ourselves and testing our thoughts out in
the world. >> 10 words or less summarize the topic.
social commentary on the internet, social social dynamics on
the internet and the differences from you know face to face dynamics.
I didn't I didn't get it all down. You could cut it down to 10
from that. That's I assume that's what it is, right? That's what
it sounded like the the woman was talking about like how do we
describe the difference? What what are the fundamental differences
between inerson interactions and online interactions? And why
does it why is it that online interactions devolve into something
so cutting and so
to to like the people that are being snarked on world?
Wrong. It's about Israel and Apac. There's no chance this about
Israel and Apac. Shut the [__] up. There's no chance
that this this whole topic is about Israel and Apac. There's
no way that these conversations are coming out and it's about
Israel or Apac. There's no shot
in this entire planet of Earth. Hold on. >> Uh guests here
with us today. Today want to take
uh the first scholar society
from this class. Um our office hours
that you're
>> now this is just an open Q&A.
I've learned from you
for us as a see we do in this classroom. It's probably >> ah
you you got me. I thought for a second it was about that >> which
you
but is that what it >> I thought Listen is Warren Smith
so there's always a chance it just totally takes off and goes
to a crazy place
>> but alas >> feels like most of the time I don't
spend a lot of time getting comments making comments. So but
is that what it feels like? Does it feel like to most people
that you're if you put content out and you get comments back
you feel like you're getting feedback? you're
>> I think it's going to vary on comment. Now, I have not
been this. They're they're on the receiving end is the student,
right? So, yes, this is an audience that tend they're there to
watch because they enjoy the content already. It might be very
different for if a student comes up here and a knucklehead like
me comes along and shares my thoughts on it and then a million
people say or 500,000 or whatever it is and then they some comments
are going to be more strongly worded than others. The question
is is
am I doing something wrong by making that video which was a real
question I had to ask myself in the wake of that video because
there was concern of don't
don't throw the be careful not to throw a student under the bus
and what we are doing here is very important and don't jeopardize
that and I'm thinking I have to ask myself am I doing something
that could cause this to be shut down cuz if one day and I told
Sam this if one day someone does come along like they did with
me and to shut this down. It will be over hurt feelings from
comments. Probably not even anything they can point to. They
probably won't even have an example. It will be the potential
of what a student might see. And I think that's nonsense. I think
you can handle it. It's going to make you stronger in the long
run. >> Yeah. I don't I don't think that's what Yeah. I
don't think that's what would shut it be a problem. >> And
wait, there's a there's some Are there questions or comments?
Yeah. Yeah.
I yeah I
>> I just had an interesting perspective and thought. So
with everything that you're saying where you
kind of you don't really care if I'm misspeaking. You just said
a little bit ago you don't really care about the politics of
it and you're not trying to push a specific agenda. Correct.
Like in the videos you've made. >> It's not political for
me. It's there are principles in the world that I think are important,
but it's not about getting a politician elected or pulling representing
the Republican line, >> but there are principles of of
like equity I think is a very bad idea. And I can break down
those reasons. >> Yeah. But also you one of the things
that you really demand is like a lot of logic like make your
your arguments have to be logical, right? That's that's like
it's a high test. Yeah. But anyway, yeah. So, in the name of
that, wouldn't you say that the titles to a lot of your videos
do kind of allude to the support of one side or the other and
in the sense of like bolding liberal exposed or conservative
exposes leftist view?
>> Don't you think you do the enlightened centrist thing,
but you're actually just doing a right-wing rift?
Yes. Warren should think this. >> Yes. This is something
I struggle with every time because I'm like,
if I don't if you don't you're playing with this title and When
you get the combination of these silly words correct, it can
mean the difference between a million people watch the video,
100,000,
and then you switch it. People do AB testing, and then there's
the thumbnail. What do I put those four words on the thumbnail?
Am I misrepresenting the meat and potatoes of the video?
But if I don't get that, is it is it unethical to to play with
that combination so that people will engage with the meat and
potatoes or do I play it super straight, super
accurate, like the way that would be more ethical, but the video
doesn't perform, right? And then there's other considerations
because I am doing this for a living and that yeah, there's plenty
plenty of criticism that can come with that. >> You know,
can can we can we just question you say your thoughts about it?
Oh yeah, that makes complete sense. And I was taking it into
consideration before you explained because again, >> okay,
hold on. I'm going to go back to Warren Smith's video here because
unfortunately that whole long form format, it's not terrible.
But I do want to I do want to keep watching this. I just want
to see
I I just like I like the offset of what he cuts versus how the
video looks, right? Sorry. What he cuts and then the actual reality.
He's like He's like doing plastic surgery
on his own terrible public speaking.
>> I just scrolled through a few of your videos right now,
right? >> Which is awesome. >> Yeah. That's like
what? In like five minutes. In five minutes, you already made
a comment by just scrolling through some videos right now and
like yo yo yo
dog.
you're going to detect that path where most of the time it is
someone who's just no offense but has watched a minute and and
making an observation. Things continued along that route where
I noticed it was not about the logic or any of the issues that
I've talked about. It was all about the person. >> I I
just had an interesting perspective and thought. So with everything
that you're saying where you
kind of you don't really care if I'm misspeaking. You just said
a little bit ago, you don't really care about the politics of
it and you're not trying to push a specific agenda. Correct.
Like in the videos you've made, >> it's not political for
me. It's there are principles in the world that I think are important,
but it's not about getting a politician elected or pulling representing
the Republican line. Like equity, I think, is a very bad idea.
And I can break down those reasons. Logic exists independent
of us. That's why I constantly say, make it about the logic and
not the person. >> Yeah. I had a question for Warren. Um,
I kind of wanted to question like your credibility. Like why,
[laughter]
>> dude? What >> should someone even spend the time
watching your videos? Why should someone follow you? Why should
somebody want to hear your opinion on like >> Dude, that
was like even worse than the other guy. That was [laughter]
other guy's like, "Dude, I just don't think you have like anything
interest." She's like, "I don't think you should even be speaking.
>> I question your ability to speak
>> videos that you review." >> Oh my god, that is
such a good question. >> And I've never seen your videos
>> but I'm just like learning about you for the first time
now, and I'm thinking
>> okay, like, why should I want to hear your opinion in
the first place? >> Yeah. Yeah. I can't tell you why you
should. Honestly, I I can't tell you why you should like something.
I can't tell you why you should want something. Perhaps this
is being too technical, but I do think it's important. So, >> that's
it's been a surprise to me. It's a good question. It's one I
contemplate every day. >> Well, I feel like anyone that
I would watch on the internet and spend my time watching. I have
a reason for why I want to hear what they have to say. So, I'm
just thinking like I don't know you at all. I don't know your
videos, but why would I want to listen to what you have to say
on some random matter? >> Yeah. But, but that's subjective.
So, there's no way that I can give you that answer. Like you
could pick a person someone you do watch and and you're like
I enjoy this person only you can explain why you enjoy that person.
All I can do is provide the logical foundation hopefully in the
d if I can make the d you're not you're not really providing
the logical foundation. You're you're trying to spice up what
you do. You're like you're giving arguments for why you think
somebody's right or wrong often they're like talk you're not
giving a logical foundation. You're not teaching people about
logic or how to apply logic like independently. You're giving
them how you think logic should be applied in individual situations.
You're giving them a fish. You're not teaching them to fish.
And sometimes the fish gone bad, bro. Sometimes the fish is not
fun or sorry, not fun.
It's not good. Okay. It's like rotten rotten fish. >> Dynamic
is clear enough.
I hope that I'm I hope that that makes it digestible and enjoyable
and if people watch it, they >> So, you don't know why
people watch you. Can I ask you? >> Why should someone
spend the time watching your videos? Like what gives you the
credibility to even comment on something that doesn't involve
yourself? >> What is credibility? Does it give me credibility
because I was a teacher for 5 years or I spent nine years in
college and I have a master's degree? Does that make me credible
or is >> wait what
nine years in college and I have a master. Does that make me
cred?
>> Isn't that like below average?
like nine years to get a bachelor's and a and a masters. I I
would have thought that's like below average. No,
I would have thought two to three years. I think once you're
getting up to like four years.
Yeah, once you're once you're getting up to four or five years
to get your masters after your bachelors or I guess maybe you
did a bachelor's in five, masters in four.
Yeah, that's what I would have thought as well. One took
Yeah, some people do take longer in their masters and some people
do like a they'll take like a holiday semester do like a fiveyear
undergrad, right?
I don't think that's particularly impressive to do like nine
years to get a master's degree in education.
>> Was it in film? I forget now. I I forget if it was in
film or in education for the masters >> or is the logic
either there or it's not? A truck driver could lay out a logical
argument. If the logic is not there, having a PhD is not going
to help you. You have to make that judgment for >> You're
non-influencer.
Wait, I literally don't [__] know what he just said
and I can't tell if it's me being out of caffeine or >> is
the logic
>> you the credibility to even comment on something that
doesn't involve yourself? >> What is credibility? Does
it give me credibility because I was a teacher for five years
or I spent nine years in college and I have a master's degree.
Does that make me credible
or is the logic either there or it's not? A truck >> or
is the logic either there or it's >> Driver could lay out
a logical argument. If the logic is not there, having a
PhD is not going to help you.
Oh, he's trying to say that
uh like certifications, certifications or credentials don't make
him correct in a situation. It's about what what are his arguments?
What is he saying? I got it. I got it. I got it. I got it. No,
he's not saying something crazy here. It's like fine, right?
He's trying to say that the credentials don't matter. You should
be able to identify why the argument is good or bad. And he's
trying to identify why other people's arguments are good or bad.
You can say that. He's just making an argument. He's not laying
out a logical foundation. He's not doing anything in terms of
teaching. He's just making an argument and letting people engage
with it. >> You have to make that. >> It's the It's
the pseudo intellectual
decor and and vibe, the aesthetic of this that appeals to like
people who think he's profound. It's not the words, it's the
aesthetic that he's not profound. Obviously, >> judgment
for yourself. >> You're non-influencer. One day that could
just stop and you won't be making any sort of income anymore.
How do you make a career out of such uncertainty?
>> Okay.
Who gave these kids mics? Shut the up.
Who asked you? Who asked you? Why don't you leave the class?
Why? Why the would you ask that? That's such a stupid question
to ask. What a What a
>> smart people are locking in their winter gear right
now while it's on sale. Bare skin is [laughter] >> Okay,
that's funny. Hold on. Him following that question with a shill
is
That is damn damn >> running a 60% off deal right now,
but only if you get your hoodie early, which is the hoodie I'm
wearing right now. This hoodie is built like a tank. 340 GSM
microfleece tin pocket minute. You'll get free USware text again
a call
60% off. Text Warren to 360. Okay, let's uh let's skip ahead
to her little segment here where she starts talking. Where's
she yapping at? Do we skip it? We go past it.
Where's this girl in the audience? I thought she was the next
one up.
Oh, I need to go like this, right?
>> Oh, here we go. Here we go.
>> but how do you know though? like credible to what your
>> good example of the recent be
in a whole
>> I could do in who has a a question or comment but how
is that even a question
>> but I mean I can also answer your question if you want
can you repeat that or how very often you think about that especially
if you're ever using any sort of like AI source you definitely
have to think about that and if it's like credible to what you're
learning in class, if you can like use it as a resource or not.
I think especially in this day and age. Um, >> but how
do you know though? Like how do you know cuz it's so everpresent
like >> How do you have he keeps asking >> Um, I
kind of wanted to question >> videos that you Why should
someone follow you? Why should somebody want to hear your opinion
on like videos that you review? >> Oh my god, that is such
a good question. I've never seen your videos personally, but
I'm just like learning about you for the first time now, and
I'm thinking >> okay, like why should I want to hear your
opinion in the first place? >> Yeah. I can't tell you why
you should, honestly. I
>> I can't answer that.
>> it's been a surprise to me. It's a good question. It's
one I contemplate every >> Like, what [laughter] >> I
think about it for myself every Why would Why should I expect
any first off any student Hang on one second. You have a response
to it. So, but why should I expect any student to even come into
my class? En you literally have been hired by the the university
charges a money. It hires professors. Those professors presumably
have to actually fulfill their duties. There's an entire institution
that backs your credibility.
What the are you asking
in class? >> Well, I feel like you have credibility.
>> Well, so you have a lot of experience teaching this
class, so I feel like that's why people sign up. Yeah, but no,
but that's but that's that's an answer. Like that's a part of
your credibility. So I'm [laughter] >> Dude, the the woman
who's sitting here is like, "Oh my god,
>> the the two men on the stage with me are
>> Wondering like >> Yeah, that professor is just
protecting Warren. It's very funny. >> Why should someone
spend the time watching your videos? Like what gives you the
credibility to even comment on something that doesn't involve
yourself? >> Yeah, just I think that's a good thing
think out loud if you could.
Why would someone wa spend the time to watch Tim Pool? What gives
Tim Pool credibility or most >> I have no idea who that
is. >> Okay. So, [laughter]
Tim Pool Megal. Okay. >> And and it's and I've been thinking
about that. I've realized I think it's >> she's just li
is she just lying? Is this person just chaos?
Is this person I feel like she's just
>> Perceived value. It's something similar to when we start
to view to pay attention to someone. They're famous because they're
famous. I'm not saying I'm but there that is a stage of celebrity.
Something that occurs a lot. >> Well, I feel like anyone
that I would watch on the internet and spend my time watching.
I have a reason for why I want to hear what they have to say.
So, I'm just thinking like I don't know you at all. I don't know
your videos, but why would I want to listen to what you have
to say on >> Oh, this guy's asking why I didn't read like
some of the documents. I get what you're saying here. Uh, threats
to guy. I get what you're saying. Oh, I just highlighted the
wrong message. I get what you're saying. Somebody's asking me
why I don't read like Pixie's full thing on the docket or whatever
the judge is saying um why she can still file like a response
saying why she couldn't make it. I understand that her lawyers
could have just filed the protective order and then there wouldn't
even be anything. It wouldn't be another issue. I do think it's
very funny that
Destiny's lawyers want to go after her for this when they said
she couldn't be there and then they they, you know, noticed her
for it. It's like very funny. It's all contrived. We'll see how
much the judge wants to deal with it.
Yeah. I Well, I read that docket entry then. If you just want
me to read the docket entry, I did read that docket entry just
maybe later in the stream than whatever you watch for the VOD
>> on some random matter. >> Yeah. But but that's
subjective. So there's no way that I can give you that answer.
Like you could pick a person someone you do watch and and you
like I enjoy this person only you can explain why you enjoy that
person. >> All I can do is provide the logical foundation
hopefully in the d if I can make the dynamics clear enough
hope that I'm I hope that that makes it digestible and enjoyable
and if people watch it they watch. >> So you don't know
why people watch you. Can I ask you
[laughter]
>> it's a class?
Oh my god. Warren Smith. There's some there's some message board
where they're snarking Warren Smith and half of this classroom
is filled up with people who participate. Okay.
You don't you don't know why
you don't know why people watch you? No, I really don't. I just
have no idea. >> Can I Wait, can I ask you a question?
This is coming from just a few minutes that we were talking in
the back. She's laughing at him.
>> Can I ask you a question? This is coming from just a
few minutes that we were talking.
She's she's just laughing at him. This is so up.
It's so up >> in the back or no when we were driving here
and I was seeing as you were describing how you do your work
and and your um how you studied that you're more you're an artist
and but what you're you may not see yourself that way.
>> Guys, we are six subs away from another hour on the
stream. 30 bucks if we want to do another hour. We've got the
Warren Smith content here. And then I think I want to do the
Lena Con stuff. So, if we get the six subs, we can go do the
Lena Con stuff. Otherwise,
I I don't think I'm going to do supporter stream tonight. We'll
see. Supporter streams probably resume once maybe in like two
weeks or so. We a week to two weeks.
>> When you're responding right now, you sound like an
artist who's like, "I don't know what it means. You tell me what
it means. I just made it." >> Right. I just [laughter]
threw this paint on the wall here. >> Actually,
I'll wait. [clears throat] >> And And you know, you're
asking a totally fair question. Like, give me a reason to watch
it. And you're like, I don't know what it is. >> I got
you.
>> I I actually have it. >> Wait, but Sam, can I
just first go >> I just want to hear his answer first.
Oh, a role. I didn't want to say, but but I think a part of it
is because my background in editing and film making and that's
one component that maybe I can bring to the table that other
content creators don't either don't care. Wait, is he admitting
what I just said? It's it's literally just the aesthetic. It's
literally just the aesthetic. That's it. Lighting, aesthetic,
presence. Okay. As an actor, that's what makes people like his
videos. It's nothing to do with what he's saying
>> enough or don't like to do. Take that additional editing
step where that for me that's really where it comes together
and I'm able to filter out the filler and almost play find the
logic and play with it in a way that makes it
allows me to present it in a way that if you were just to play
that clip from Tim Pool or whatever, it's not the it's different
than that. So maybe that makes it more interesting for people.
Well, the then what I was going to say is think about the first
person who you say the people who you follow you watch well well
you you started with with somebody cuz someone you encountered
them and then you're like okay now I you suddenly start to watch
that person well that's how people end up watching Warren or
watching this class.
>> Yep. So then how do you make a career out of I don't
know why people watch me but I just get views and knowing that
you're not an influencer. One day that could just stop and you
won't be making any sort of income anymore. How do you make a
career out of such uncertainty?
>> You're right. Yeah. You voluntarily enter the unknown.
It is uncertain. But when you're in that uncertainty,
that's where the rewards are going to exist. As opposed to where
I went in every day as a teacher, it's very comforting when they
tell you this is exactly what you need to do. this is what time
you go home. That's all you got to worry about. And you're going
to get a paycheck, but there's not that potential upside that
you're going to get when you are in the unknown where I don't
know what I'm going to be doing tomorrow. It is move to move.
You asked something interesting right there. I'm trying to Oh,
given that it could vanish or well, I I'm able to make a living
because people >> like tomorrow your video could get no
views and then you're not going to get >> You're absolutely
right. >> Which is okay. But that's all right. That's it's
always like an interesting thing that I think there's a there's
like a dynamic where
probably you should be earning as much or more quite easily than
whatever like regular career opportunities you've h you'd have
right in order to do like this job because of the risk you should
be making like maybe 1.5 to 2x
with some understanding that you could go back to that previous
career you want to keep up like your training or something once
you're making like five or 10 times though which is the case
for some creators, right? Like someone like Nicholas Dioro, he's
doing like a regular IT job. He's got to be almost he's got to
be like 5 to 10xing what his previous career was earning him,
right? Once you're there, I firmly believe that it's stupid to
keep the old job. And I've I actually there was like a spat of
influencers who denied this who were like Mudahar was like, "Oh,
I'll never quit my real job because I never want to be relying
on on video making." And it's like, oh, that's a totally position
when you have a channel as popular as his. And then it came out
that he was just lying about the other job. Yeah, there's just
no reason if you can make 3x or more of what your regular job
is, you are a [__] to just stay in that regular job.
If you have some hope of continuing on with the the influencer
thing for a little bit, maybe 3x is low. 5x 100% though. You
switch over like
I saw there was like um there's a couple like Dota players who
were like this who who were making hundreds of thousands of dollars
a year as like 16 17 18 year olds and then they're like uh I
don't think this is going to be like continuable. I want to go
to school. I'm like dude that is the dumbest. You're making hundreds
of thousands of dollars a year US at like 16.
Stop thinking you should go to school right now. I mean, yeah,
you're probably doing profound social damage to yourself, okay,
in terms of your ability to socialize and stuff. You might be
doing some damage that way, but you have no idea the economic
situation you're starting life off with. It's crazy how well
you're going to be doing.
Like, if you just if you can just drop this into like some investments,
you start school a year or two late and then you and then you
get back, okay? Then you that you have those investments, you
just literally put it in the S&P 500 and you're set. You're
like set for so long. >> All right. Look, it's the same
with me with any teacher. Like I don't >> No, it is not.
No, it is not. No, it is not because of your credibility. You've
shown that you can't understand. This guy is undermining his
credibility every single time he speaks.
It wasn't about them streaming Barry. They were making that much
money from competitions and stuff, but it's it's like if you're
making like $300,000 in a year as a 16-year-old,
that's like crazy for your for your life. I don't know. I was
like, "Bro, you should take a year off for that. You You might
be able to take a year off without like a lot of penalty for
that." Does Warren have a degree? He's got a masters. I don't
I >> You're employed by the university, >> No, no,
no. But listen, but I'm only employed by the university because
I have a because I bring students to my class. There are a lot
of people who teach and people don't go to their classes. And
like me, I'm not a tenure faculty member. So, for me, it's like
year by year by year. And so when I started out,
I didn't know that students would sign up for my class. And like
then they did, but all along the way I'm wondering like, wait,
are they going to continue to sign up? Are they not going to
sign up? So it's very it's similar in a it's a very similar way.
Um, >> so wait, you is there another comment? Someone who
hasn't spoken yet,
Can you Good
questions by the way. Oh, can you go? >> Dude, good good
questions. By the way, Warren's just been raped like thoroughly.
Warren's so done.
Oh, film making is his uh his masters of fine arts. Okay. Bachelor
of Fine Arts. Okay. So, he got with his masters he was able to
become a teacher in like a film school or I think he might have
taught in a high school or a community college, a film class.
I think that's what he was >> Can you go over there to
Yeah. right there in the hive. Yeah.
>> Go ahead, bro.
>> Um, I just wanted to like follow up on her kind of and
give a reason cuz she you said you don't know why people watch
you. And I will say after the Charlie Kirk video, I did start
watching you >> Uh-oh. It's a true It's a Warren Smith
true believer in the audience. >> And I just wanted to
give a little like representation on why people do follow your
content. And I believe a lot of
growing up I watched a lot of like Fox and CNN lived in a both
like middle ground household. And I would say over the years
I progressively started watching my parents watch less like mainstream
media which means I have to go out and watch it on my own. And
I heard another kid say like why do you you're just a commentator.
You don't really like give your own opinion. And I just want
to say I watch you cuz I believe that you fairly represent
kind of like both sides. Not really like you're right leaning
but you can give the perspective of what a person's trying to
give in digestible clips which works out for the viewer. And
then >> I I understand this is like the exact person this
like this guy is the personification
of why
democracy is going to be the end of the world.
I think >> even if I don't agree with your statement, I'm
able to weigh the two and then see which way I kind of go about
it. So, like if I'm watching you and you say something conservative,
but I agreed more with the person in this class that said something
very liberal leaning, I'm going to kind of go with that narrative
instead of following yours. But that doesn't mean I can't watch
your content. I believe giving fair news is like
kind of the point of being a political commentator
because a lot of political commentators now a day are scared
to hurt their like funders like major political party representatives.
So that's why your news is a healthy balance and allows us to
find like little niche people that give their perspective on
modern day media. Yeah. And thanks for that. Yeah, that's very
>> I appreciate that. Thank you. >> You know, bro,
I don't find you to be right leaning so much as just really good
at challenging the left. Like >> that's and I was that's
what I was going to comment
because I I I think about that a lot. And like so equity for
example, I don't think of myself I don't think of myself as conservative
or liberal. Now, I know that's probably going to bother some
people like, well, yeah, you are, but like my position on equity
happens to I guess you could call that the represents the cons
the conservative view on equity. I think equity is a very bad
idea.
Toxic mas there's different topics we can go down and like oh
well that followed but >> wait what >> that landscape
will shift I I believe.
Um, wait. Do you have a a final?
>> I did. I just had one small observation and kind of
question for you. So, she gave you a really good opportunity
not to pitch. >> Never mind. We're We're good on that.
I I'll be honest. I wasn't listening to the last point about
equity.
I thought I thought he was saying something else. Cool professor.
Okay. All right,
guys.
I'm sorry. I I misunderstood what he was saying and now it makes
more sense. So now I don't even want to go back and critique
it because what he said made sense there. Okay,
with with all that said,
with all that said,
I think that's it for the stream.
Thank you everybody for being here tonight. It was very good
stream. Massive dubs. Okay, thanks everyone for being here. I'm
going to go
and I'll be back tomorrow night.
All right, I'll be back tomorrow night.
>> Oh, wait. No, there would be no Wait, hold on. Hold
on. Hold on. >> We got four minutes left. We got to We
got to finish. >> We got to finish the warm video. I forgot
just so we can get the music on the way out cuz that's what one's
been holding out for. >> Enter the unknown. It is uncertain.
But when you're in that uncertainty, that's where the rewards
are going to exist. As opposed to where I went in every day as
a teacher, it's very comforting when they tell you this is exactly
what you need to do. This is what time you go home. That's all
you got to worry about. And you're going to get a paycheck, but
there's not that potential upside that you're going to get when
you are in the unknown where I don't know what I'm going to be
doing tomorrow. It is move to move. You asked something interesting
right there. I'm trying to Oh, given that it could vanish or
well, I I'm able to make a living because people >> like
tomorrow your video could get no views and then you're not going
to get >> You're absolutely right. >> Yes, it could
end at any time. But what's your point? So because an endeavor
could come to an end, you should not embark on that endeavor.
>> So we're currently in a room of like I would assume
over give or take 500 people. So
the first answer that you provided being, oh, I don't know how
to answer that or I can't answer that. Wouldn't that solid solidify
someone's position to not watch you? Because if I'm listening
to someone, especially when they post mainly political content,
I would like to hear some defense or some like reasoning for
why I should continue to listen to their stances. But if they
were to instantly say, "Oh, I can't answer that question." I
think you should defend. >> Well, I don't think Okay. I
don't think he was saying you wouldn't defend any of his stances.
Said you don't really know his positions all that well. So maybe
you don't like it on politics. You could just like him for one
subject on politics. the living that you're making or at least
the content you're posting. >> You think I should? But
if I were here to try and sell you to watch my content, then
there would be some prerogative for me to do that, but I'm not
here to do >> No, completely. >> I actually appreciated
your answer, by the way. >> I talk about what interests
me the most when I feel like I can offer something to it. >> I
think it would hurt the content if I were to think that way.
>> Yeah. I'm I want to genuinely say what talk about what
I'm interested in and why and break it down how I see it and
not worry about how it lands. That should be what I'm striving
for. So if I'm in here telling you this is why you should be
I would be doing the opposite of that. >> That's why I
don't tune in to CNN because they seem to try and sell you on
a product. What makes Don Limon credible? Well, he went to journalism
school. Okay. As someone who has taught a journalism class and
TAed at a college level journalism course, I could tell you that
that is not enough to make you credible. Yeah. >> Wait,
he taught a journalism course.
>> Well, he went to journalism school. Okay. As someone
who has taught a >> as someone wait >> journalism
class and T8 at a college level journalism course, I could tell
you that that is not enough to make you
>> He taught a journalism class with what cred? It sounds
like he wasn't credentialed to do that. These people aren't trained
in objectivity. Well, it doesn't make a difference if you're
trained in objectivity. Doesn't mean they have objectivity, is
it? >> No one has objectivity, >> right? But some
it it's worse in certain areas, especially when you have masses
of amounts of money behind it pushing specific agendas. I I did
feel like I was wearing the kid gloves because there was this
sense of this is for the administration more than for the students
because I I think it should be about the students and just forget
the administration and that will actually achieve a better outcome.
>> Again, if this is how >> how you make your living,
it makes sense that you want people's attention to be grabbed
when they're clicking on a video. So, moving farther away, >> what
the [__] did he just say >> from the general
public, when you're talking to students and when you're making
videos about students and what they're saying? How do you think
it's beneficial for the student? It may be beneficial for you
to have that bolded title and for you to have that kind of hook
grabber, but people are going to see that and associate it with
a college course that they're not in and then watch parts of
the video or all of the video and then lean on your title for
the content of your video. Does that make sense? >> Yeah.
I hope that they lean on what they're actually seeing in the
video. And I am condensing. We're taking an hour and a half class
and I'm taking what I think is most interesting and important
in condensing that in my perspective down to 10 minutes and this
is a fair criticism that I'm going to always get because I there
is so much left out and people have a proclivity to say but I
had this brilliant point that you left out and as my guideline
is as long as I'm not deceptively editing something and misrepresenting
what you're saying I think I >> [__] I forget
what I was watching. I remember we watched something where Warren
like actually cut off the first part of whatever he was watching.
He missed like that it was a negative before
in in the way the person was speaking. There was like a negative
thing. Basically got the exact opposite meaning out of a clip
and ran with a whole video on it. I I don't think I watched Lauren
or sorry Warren very much after that.
And uh this I feel like is incredibly deceptively edited. So
I don't know.
I don't know what he's talking about. He he actually deceptively
edits maybe not the React clips but
quite a bit of his own stuff. I feel like he deceptively edits.
>> I can condense the and and accurately represent the
logic to actually make it more digestible without misrepresenting
as long as I'm staying on that. I'm going to and I might get
it wrong now and then, but that's what I'm striving striving
to do.
Wow. Wow.
Wow. Wow. Wow.
He thinks we're dumb. What happened to America first? Uhoh.
Wait.
Okay, I'll I'll think about covering this tomorrow.
>> Happy Thursday, my fellow idiots. How are you? >> Happy
Thursday, my fellow idiots.
Okay. All right. That's it, guys. We're out. We're out for the
night. Have a good night. Be back tomorrow.
Good night. Good night. Good night. Good night. I'm headed out.
Bye-bye.